so
moin kann hier auch jemand naja gut es ist fast zehn es ist normal dass man
nicht mehr pennen kann das trinken auch schnell
exquisite cute chat am start wieder ich sehe es schon
ja ich sage ich habe schon öfters mal im stream welche gesagt aber ich vergesse
das immer relativ schnell was ich gut fand da muss ich mir mal Gedanken
darüber machen zumindest wo ich sagen die meisten
alter was mit der musiklose die meisten der der ganzen super hyped serien fand
ich persönlich mega langweilig game of thrones fand ich übelst langweilig und
sag mal so staffel 1 bis 3 und so ging noch irgendwie aber danach war das
teilweise so krass gestreckt und auch echt so komplett an den haaren herbeigezogen
ich glaube das war wahrscheinlich so der punkt wo ihnen dann auch die buch
vorlage ausgegangen ist für manche characters keine ahnung danach habe ich
nicht mehr geguckt und breaking bad fand ich auch nicht irgendwie so den mega
krassen halb best serie ever wie alle immer so tun also habe ich auch nicht
alles geguckt wo ich echt also einer der serien wo ich wirklich richtig
enttäuscht von gewesen bin war mr robot weil die am anfang richtig nice war und
dann am ende übelst komisch geworden ist habe ich auch die ersten zwei
staffeln geguckt dann ist es auch teilweise total random geworden
ne ich bin gerade erst aufgestanden
ja vor allem was mir über mr robot genervt was mich bei mr robot genervt hat
ist so ein bisschen psychogramm ist ja ok aber da kenne ich nur den film
aber das drehte sich ja dann quasi so ab der zweiten hälfte der ersten staffel
hauptsächlich darum dass der dass der hältenden dachschaden hat also ja ich
weiß nicht ich hätte mir mehr heckermann stuff gewünscht weil das war
eigentlich ganz gut bei mr robot umgesetzt
das habe ich schon auf jetzt 93 das habe ich schon das habe ich schon auf das
wollte ich mir nachher angucken
du siehst es nicht in der place das liegt daran weil das nicht youtube
leiste ist das ist die chat ja der chat der chat browser das ist der youtube
browser
exzellent
ja leute was fangen wir dann an ich muss ich erst mal ein bisschen mit
minimalst wachwerten ja übrigens das letzte video das ist so das ist so so
typische youtube stellzka die leute fanden das video eigentlich ziemlich
gut wenn du überlegst 403 comments instant aber wirklich wirklich gesehen
hat es keiner das liegt aber wahrscheinlich daran weil das jetzt nicht
so das thema ist was viele anspricht ja
das ist bester hintergrund das ist bester hintergrund zum pool stream oder
man kann auf youtube nur noch echt schwer durchblicken wann was geguckt
wird man nicht ist zahlen wir alle der porn browser was meinst du warum ich den
extra streaming account habe dass ich nicht meine history liegen muss
pool streams auf youtube ich habe ich habe letztens ein comment gesehen von
einem dass youtube sein pool stream video gesperrt hat wo er quasi nur twitch
ausschnitte reingemacht hat was lustig finde wegen zu freizügigen sachen was
witzig ist weil es kommt ja direkt von von twitch ist ok wisst ihr warum ich
übrigens denke also was war so das dilemma von twitch bar pool streams ist
also ich habe ich habe mir das ich habe mir das überlegt also wenn man wenn man
sagen würde hey prinzipiell ist in pool streams was was man als content haben
möchte auf der seite also mal angenommen man hätte sich dafür
entschieden auch auf twitch seite was ja wohl offensichtlich so ist sonst gibt
es das nimmer und genau das sehe ich sehe ich genau die twitch wird das
wahrscheinlich verbieten aber habe ich überlegt es wäre auch cool wenn man den
kram wenigstens filtern könnte weil ich habe kein bock dass beispielsweise in
meinen recommendations wie spricht man das aus als empfehlung zu haben oder
sonstige ich will davon eigentlich gar nicht sehen habe ich mir gedacht ok man
könnte doch eigentlich eine extra kategorie für so was machen oder extra
tech aber das wird es nicht geben und zwar aus
einem grund also ich dachte auch erst eine kategorie wäre gut aber das wird es
nicht geben nämlich genau aus dem grund weil twitch dann so in irgendwie so in
der zwick mühle ist
ja so das ist ein kaster das ist ein custom custom add-on das ist natürlich
wieder was anderes also wird just birthing genau irgendwie so was die
werden das die werden das nicht machen weil sobald sie eine kategorie sich
ausdenken müssen müssen sie das problem benennen oder was ist das problem
benennen sie müssen es irgendwie nennen und dadurch dass sie sich dann dort mit
dieser dieser frage beschäftigen müssen sich irgendwas ausdenken müssen heißt
das auch im gleichen schluss sie müssen quasi offiziell zugeben dass sie quasi
nennen wenn es mal soft core porn sub genre haben auf ihrer plattform in dem
moment und das werden sie wahrscheinlich nicht machen wollen weil twitch ist auf
der einen seite eine plattform die ultra bedacht darauf ist in letzten jahren
auch ich will ich sagen vielleicht family friendly aber auf jeden fall
möglichst ja freundlich offen für jeden und und brav ich kann es nicht wie es
alles also möglichst family friendly zu sein sagen wir mal einfach so und auf der
anderen seite dann sowas also das passt nicht zusammen aber mein klar
letztendlich bringt es kohle dort die twitch ja wie gesagt ich finde das auch
nicht toll aber deswegen wird es da wahrscheinlich keine extra kategorie
für geben weil sobald sie eine extra kategorie verschaffen müssen müssten
sie sich eingestehen dass sie einen soft core porn sub genre hier auf twitch
haben und das werden sie nicht machen wollen
jetzt just chatting gucken wir doch mal wie viele pools übrigens die die
diskussion über über pool streams gehen meiner meinung nach vollkommen in die
falsche richtung ja die sind wieder so typische empörungsdiskussion wieder so
nach dem motto wie du möchtest keine pool streams auf twitch haben frauen haben
auch rechte wie kannst du dagegen sein das ist überhaupt nicht das thema ich
glaube niemand oder was heißt niemand es gibt immer welche aber ich glaube kaum
einem geht es wirklich darum gegen frauenrechte zu sein wenn er keine pool
streams sehen will dann habe ich gesehen ein paar influencer dudes haben auf
twitter reacted so nach dem motto ja pool streams nicht gut finden aber aber
slot machines promoten und sonst was ich weiß gar nicht ich weiß gar nicht was
das für ein komischer vergleich sein soll ersten ich finde auch slot slot
machine casino klücks spiel streams nicht sind nicht gut auf twitch aber das
eine hat mit dem anderen erst mal überhaupt nichts zu tun
also wie gesagt ich will wenn es amig ich möchte beides nicht angezeigt
bekommen und es geht absolut nicht im frauenrechte selbstverständlich und
diese diskussion darüber zeigt schon mal wie wie emotional mittlerweile um jeden
um jeden kram diskutiert wird ich glaube es will keiner den mädels des
recht absprechen oder sagen die sind blöd weil mal ganz ehrlich solange dass
die twitch tos gestatten und die mädels das machen das ist ja nichts
verwerfliches uns hat nichts mit frauenrechten zu tun dass sie das nicht
dürfen dass es jemand nicht will was immer die selbstverständlich dürfen sie
das und sie sind clever dass sie es ausnutzen ja da kannst du eigentlich gar
nichts dagegen sagen also jetzt die mädels dies ausnutzen zu halten ergibt
ja keinen sinn es wurde es wurden koreanische streamerinnen gebannt weil
sie sich umgezogen haben auf der kamera und haben die kamera irgendwie schlecht
eingestellt oder zu früh eingeschaltet oder was auch immer man hat sie beim
umziehen gesehen da wurden koreanische mädels gebannt
ich weiß aber nicht ich weiß aber nicht ob das die die gleichen sind ja also
das wie gesagt die diskussion um frauenrechte finde ich jetzt paar
poolsteams irgendwie recht unangebracht es geht eigentlich eher um den content
wo man sich gedanken machen muss ob das was ist oder wo man quasi so als als
twitch community sagt ja das ist content den wir auf einer hauptsächlich
gaming stream seite haben wollen klar twitch geht immer noch ein bisschen in
die andere richtung mittlerweile und fördert immer mehr andere sachen aber
das ist ja die eigentliche frage die man sich stellen muss
was ist das ich mache es auf ist das irgendwie wer wann wie wo schon gebannt
wurde
oder was oder was oder wie bent bent bent bent was sagt uns das jetzt hier
sind pool streamer ja da haben sie wahrscheinlich die ganze sache ein wenig
überspannt ja natürlich bewegste dich da auf dünnem eis
weil ich news dazu gelesen habe
was ich ja auch ein bisschen schade finde
also was ich also eine thematik die mir finde ich auch ein bisschen kurz kommt
bei dieser diskussion um pool streams und sonst was wie gesagt also dass man
irgendwie die diskussion da auf auf frauenrechte beschränkt finde ich trifft
den kern des themas nicht habe ich ja schon gesagt wie gesagt ich würde
keinem der medels irgendwie wollen dass sie das nicht mehr dürfen oder wie
gesagt ich bin sogar der mann sind relativ clever wenn sie es ausnutzen das
ist eher die frage möchte man sowas generell auf der plattform haben und
was ich ja persönlich ein bisschen schade finde das geht jetzt das geht aber
auch so ein bisschen in die richtung richtig genau es geht aber auch so ein
bisschen in die richtung frauenrechte und zwar hat sich mal jemand gedanken
drüber gemacht wie das ist für streamer innen wie man das so schön sagt also
für weibliche streamer die vielleicht sogar drei vier jahren versuchen sich
den channel aufzubauen oder aufgebaut haben und dort mit unterhaltung schräg
strich okay mag okay unterhaltung dass ich weg vielleicht geht für den ein oder
anderen ja auch am pool regeln als unterhaltung durch aber mit gaming
skills zu überzeugen und sich eine zuschauer base aufzubauen um quasi auch
zu zeigen er guckt mal mittels können das auch mittels können auch gut spielen
mittels können auch zuschauer anlocken nicht rein durch weibliche reize wie
muss das denn für so jemand sein der das quasi die letzten jahre versucht hat
sich sowas aufzubauen oder legen sich drei medels an pool und haben
innerhalb der ersten zwei tage mehr zuschauer als sie die letzten fünf jahre
zusammen hatte wenn er postet hey wird mich nicht wundern wenn das ein paar
versucht hätten aber weibliche pool streams laufen garantiert deutlich
besser ja und übrigens da sind sich bei dieser frage sind sich die medels
tatsächlich selbst gar nicht einig es hat eine auf weiß nicht wer ein bisschen
größere trittschnipp hat ja auf twitter gepostet was ist hier auf twitch los so
viel pool so sieht aus wie porno seite und dann haben dann da haben dann andere
medels darauf geantwortet du du bist nur neidisch auf die pool streamerinnen du
bist hier am slut shame und ich wusste bis dahin gar nicht dass überhaupt dass
ein existentes wort ist also sprich die medels sind sich da selbst selbst nicht
einig wie man das über das ganze sehen sollte ja ja ich wirklich wusste ich
dass es das wort überhaupt gibt also da gibt es da gibt es auch so in den eigenen
rein zwischen weiblichen streamer so ziemliche ziemliche kämpfe ja also so
klar so klar ist da die die meinung zu gar nicht und ich kann es verstehen ohne
mist ich kann echt verstehen also wenn ich wenn ich mich mal da rein
versetze die wenn ich mich mal rein versetzt ich wäre wirklich eine
weibliche streamerin die versucht zuschauer zu überzeugen durch durch
gaming skills durch unterhaltung skills mich zu gucken und ich habe mir da auch
was aufgebaut und es ist gut und ich gucke dann um die ecke und sie einer
es hat zwei tagen da hält ihre tippen in die kamera liegt am pool hat innerhalb
von zwei tagen quasi zehn mal so viele zuschauer
geil fände ich es nicht also ich wenn ich mich da rein versetzt kann ich es schon
irgendwie nachvollziehen dass man da auch nicht so ganz zufrieden drüber ist
zuweilen die ganze sache ursprünglich mal als gaming seite gestartet ist ich
finde es nicht so schlecht dass twitch so ein bisschen expanded in unterschiedliche
richtungen also sprich dass es hier diese science and technology streams gibt
just chatting finde ich auch an sich keine schlechte kategorie aber das geht
halt schon eine ganze ecke von weg und übrigens ich habe es ja mal vor einer
weile gesagt wisst ihr von wem ich als einziges zutrauen oder zugetraut hätte
eine konkurrenz aufzubauen für twitch ich mein mixer und microsoft haben es
ja nicht haben es ja nicht geschafft aber ohne scheiß würde pornhub ins gaming
business expanden ich würde den sogar echt ich würde den sogar echt chancen
ausrechnen
weil die haben einfach riesige mega zuschauer base und man könnte auch sehr
viel mit dem content verbinden den sie da schon haben also die haben wir dort
dort auch creators die hunderttausende fans haben und alles also facebook gaming
keck weight facebook gaming mag vielleicht für die ein oder andere
channel funktionieren aber ohne mist ich habe schon mal in dem video gesagt wenn
wenn die immer auf die den einzigen den ich da wirklich irgendwie chancen
ausrechnen würde twitch konkurrenz zu machen wäre pornhub gaming
aber ich glaube ich glaube da haben sie keine ambition natürlich natürlich
müsste sich dann natürlich müssen die sich dann ein bisschen besser
positionieren bei dem ganzen weil die hatten ja nicht die mussten nicht um
sonst letztens erst wie viele videos haben sie gelöscht 10
millionen videos oder so von von von 12 millionen auf zwei millionen videos
runter löschen wenn du konntest auf du konntest auf pornhub
bei der die diskussion wurden ja hauptsächlich geführt um irgendwelchen
also warum pornhub die sachen gelöscht hat ne also da wurden ja diskussionen
geführt um sachen die hochgeladen wurden ohne einwilligung oder um so
revenge porn und sonstige geschichten aber wisst ihr wisst ihr was auch ein
problem ist also unabhängig mal von den illegalen pornsachen die da drauf waren
es war auch ein problem dass pornhub die sachen komplett ignoriert hat und du
konntest da avengers endgame gucken auf pornhub in 1080p das hat keinen
interessiert
also das war copyright technisch nicht so auf der sicheren seite die seite und
da war es kein wunder dass über kurz oder lang dort die content an anrücken
und sagen hier mach weg hätten sie das nicht so vernachlässigt
die letzten fünf jahre mit man auger auf den content haben dann wäre es
wahrscheinlich gar nicht so weit gekommen sieht man ja jetzt auch schon
dass die mit dem gibt's ja frag mich nicht warum ich das all ich bin mir gar
nicht sicher warum ich das überhaupt weiß alles ja die haben wir jetzt schon
wieder das problem dass du musst jetzt ja du musst jetzt ja dort zertifiziert
sein also ihr seht jede video seite hat so ihre
eigenen probleme du musst ja dort zertifiziert sein dass du hochladen
kannst allerdings ist diese zertifizierung voll die prüfung für
diese zertifizierung so lasch dass es jetzt ganz viele quasi channels dort
gibt die vorher nennen wir es mal nicht autorisierten kram hochgeladen haben die
haben sich jetzt einfach die haben sich jetzt einfach einen
authentifizierten channel gemacht und laden dort wieder den gleichen kram hoch
der auch nicht dadurch wo sie nicht auf einmal die rechte dafür haben also diese
zettel diese diese diese aktivierung und so was von denen ihrer seite muss sehr
lasch sein also sprich die haben jetzt wieder die gleichen probleme wie vorher
nur dass ein häkchen am kanal dran ist was war das
ich will jetzt nicht nachgucken ob tanzverbot wieder seinen channel
reaktiviert hat die habe ich noch nicht weiter gemacht aber ich das steht auf
jeden fall auf beim plan dass ich mir das mal angucke definitiv alderlahn
so was was ist was ist eine matze ausbildung oder matze ausbildung sagt
mir gar nichts
kann man danach kann man danach suchen ist das ist das monka tos
ah mathematisch technische software signal habe ich noch nie habe ich noch
nie was dazu ich weiß ich weiß nicht was das ist keine ahnung habe ich noch nie
gehört
im mod slot von exzellent mache ich gleich rein
zu checker keks alda
den lief das lief das lief brauche noch das lief ist auch mega geil
obwohl packer ist geedet er bei the way nene moment mein moment
warte mal warte mal ich habe das wieder removed ich habe das wieder removed
weil ich habe schon wo packt drinne mach mal mach mal besser wenn es dir nicht zu
viel ausmacht ja mach mal lieber anstatt wo packer wo lief mit der animation in
auf bei der twitch tv weil da habe ich nicht den den den den den ähnlich das
ähnlich immer schon drin
bei the way wir haben zwei neue emotes weiß ich ob ihr es gesehen habt
exzellent
wenig wenig
die arbeiten samstag warum das denn saurei
telekom und wurde davon haben jetzt filternett moment hatten wir das nicht
erst letztens wauder phone ich kann semper video nicht richtig nachmachen
es ist da mussten muss man wauder phone ich kann es das funktioniert nicht
das ist jemanden kann man echt schlecht nachmachen
der sagt ja auch dann gerne so was die so die sogenannten die die provider
sagt er dann immer gerne
wo blieb hier top top emote das finde ich so geil alter wo blieb das ist so
geiles emote also ich habe jetzt hinzugefügt mal gucken ob es das
gecheckt hat schon ist drin moment ich bin frech ich bin frech mal chat chat
wupp lief was lief groß oder klein wo blieb wo blieb eine so nicht drin aber
wie gesagt ihr seht ich habe hinzugefügt es dauert wahrscheinlich einfach ein
bisschen bis das bis es das mitgekriegt hat falls es bei euch funktioniert sagt
schalt dann probiere ich sie auch noch mal aus was das das nix von mir aber
wo wurscht also schon da ist immer uns darf also für die ganzen waut muss man
sagen muss ich im chain law jetzt mal einen sub giften er gibt sich da echt
mühe massive dass er seine eigenen emote wenigstens verwenden kann alter
es wäre sonst auch fail oder so exquisite sehr schön so gut also was
schauen wir uns denn ach so ich sollte ich sollte ja über die just chatting
kategorie mal drüber skollen wie viele pool camps ich sehe ok das war mal jetzt
mal ganz schnell just moment sind es nur deutsche channels
ja ok excellent excellent erst mal schon ach nee das ist meiner weil sie öfters
aufmachen wahrscheinlich excellent erst mal erst mal pool streams moment
männlicher pool stream wait a minute keck wait männlicher pool stream ja ok das
zählt nicht wirklich oder ich bin auf recommended recommended for you alter
warum ich habe ich habe was der hell ich habe ich habe keine davon bisher
geguckt warum ist es recommended für mich ok ok wir machen wir machen wir
machen recommended mal aus viewers ok es gibt ok erst mal 8,2 k pool stream dann
irgendwelche glücksspiel stream oder was es ist keine ahnung es ist zu früh für
pool streams wahrscheinlich ja so was ähnliches wie pool stream und und
unterwäsche stream ok hat man jetzt nix keine ahnung klamotten an probier
stream pole dance stream ok das ist übelst anstrengend männlicher pool
stream
ausschnitt stream dance stream fake pool stream
anime stream was auch immer
plus 18 moment das ist überhaupt nicht erlaubt auf twitch oder ist es fast
anderes nicht 18 plus es ist plus 18 alles klar ausschnitt stream just
watching stream was auch immer
echt der erste oder der zweite richtige richtig echte pool stream im bett
liegen stream was auch immer ok um die urzeit hält sich da noch
halbwegs in grenzen oder doppel doppel badestream
ja ja ja stream
ja hält sich hält sich doch gerade noch echt in grenzen oder das liegt an der
urzeit ich weiß ich weiß abends ist es voll abends ist das voll mit mit
solchen solchen streams aber aktuell legt es vielleicht auch daran dass die
leute noch schlafen ich glaube selbst in den usa ist noch nicht pool stream zeit
ja gibt nicht so viel ok komm leute guck mal mal witz hast du eigentlich auch so
katzenohren für dein headset natürlich ich habe das auch immer auf aber ihr
seht es halt nicht ich habe nicht nur katzenohren headset ich habe sogar auch
so eine mütze
kennst du windows neuen terminal font
ne
aber das ist das ist kein offizieller microsoft font das meint es hat sechs
sterne auf github das ist bestimmt nicht der offizielle
microsoft font mit sechs sternen auf github
geht das jetzt ich refresh mal geht wo blieb jetzt
wo blieb nein geht nicht also wie gesagt du hast gesehen ich habe es hinzugefügt
na was sagst du zum stream von ludwig oder ladwick wie auch immer das korrekt
ausspricht und seinem insane sub record ich habe das nur am rande mit verfolgt
wie lang hat er denn jetzt am ende gestreamt wie geht bei mir geht es doch
nicht keck keck weight warum nicht
kaputt gehnisch gehnisch proken
refreshen alle was meinst du was ich die ganze zeit gemacht habe schon wir können
trick 17 machen guck mal wir passen mal auf massive massive trick ihr geht hier
hin am moment disable cache habe ich schon so und jetzt noch mal
mein mein mein jetzt siehst du browser hacks zehn tricks den nicht mal die
browser hersteller selber wissen google hasst diesen hack
iop artis stellts ja
du du du du wieso machen es eigentlich im browser so schwer ohne cash zu laden
ja das wüsste ich auch gern
oh das ist natürlich heftig
er hat 242.000 subs ok easy money erstmal eine halbe millionen
zips twitch subscriber in dem monat nicht schlecht guter stundenlohn
ja übrigens huge des dassi modes wirklich geil da geht auch erst einen
schritt weg tritt sich noch mal um es geht erst ein schritt weg tritts noch mal
um und dann geht er weiter schau ab irgendein streamer dude den ich sonst
nicht gucke habe ich ich habe ich habe ich guck mal sogar pulsa uns am start
die hälfte die hälfte das heißt im prinzip wenn euch twitch mit dem
subtrain gebadet dann bringt das eigentlich zur hälfte amazon was deswegen
sage ich auch immer dass das gemt rein ich habe gar keinen vertrag ich habe
gar keinen vertrag in dem sinn ich habe das ganz normale standard ding was was
jeder hat
kann ich mir nicht vorstellen so groß wie der ist
wenn man 10.000 subs hat ja wie viel subs habe ich eigentlich gerade aktuell
das mich mal kurz nachgucken
in die primus bevor ich nachgucke so was haben wir denn also ok also im prinzip
eigentlich so viel wie immer so ungefähr in dem dreh wie immer excellent
sage ich jetzt nicht weil wir machen nachher noch mal eine runde raten und
wenn ihr ja dran ist kriegt ein wollen wir das jetzt machen
ok leute moment moment noch nicht anfangen und ich anfangen also ok also
ratet mal ratet mal wie viel subs ich habe ab jetzt
ja für alle die bei weihnachten dabei waren die haben jetzt noch ein bisschen
zu hohe sachen im kopf weil an weihnachten war es natürlich deutlich
höher aber immer so ok 3 2 1 stopp gott je nach zählt nicht mehr also ich habe
subs quake wo ist es hin 200 4 und 60
ob das einer gemacht hat nein das nein das nein
ok da muss jetzt echt der muss jetzt echt da muss jetzt echt den kram
durchgucken oder was alter wer ist am nächsten dran
wer ist am nächsten dran dass gerade es kann ich doch jetzt überhaupt nicht
überprüfen alter ist sein mikrofon kaputt
nähe so alles alles wie immer oh warte mal habe ich habe ich mich so
habe ich hat a teams wiederum gestellt kein quake kein quake
du hast alles jebaited alter jebaited ok wir überprüfen das ganz einfach
wie überprüft es also als 264 in richtung 265 gibt es nicht 266 267 268 269
27 ok 270 haben wir das ist 6 weg 6 entfernt davon ok 270 ist das eine
moment wer hatte
27 der olli hat 270 ok 6 stück weg schon mal kopieren
das ist unterm strich das ist unterm strich nee dann dann ist zu spät so und
dann haben wir
vielleicht bin ich so nett und gebe trotzdem ein und dann machen wir das
ganze mal umgedreht 63 62 61 60 quake
59 58 57 56 55 auf 54 haben einige
so nie hat nur einer der aragon der kriegt ein so ich bin exquisite
der olli kriegt auch ein komm wir sind nicht so da war ja quasi schon fast noch
dabei so aber erst mal
was ist jetzt am besten da aber verschenken
bämen also im prinzip spende ich jetzt amazon 2 euro 50
warum kostet es eigentlich in euro und dollar das gleiche
ist nicht gebadet
so exquisite weiß so
bestimmt wegen steuer oder einfach weil es eine klare zahl ist und da kein
problem hat wenn er mehr kohle bekommt ok auf geht's leute gucken wir uns mal
das erste mit ein wann war gestern stream ende kurz nach 23 Uhr war richtig zu
feier jetzt hast du klug gehabt
kannst du einen monat lang poggers keks emotes verwenden wir haben wir haben
mittlerweile schon jede menge richtig nice emotes
hast du schon auf pfeiffer ein keks nähe nähe habe ich nicht
ok kommen wir uns mal ein paar videos an also was was haben wir denn hier zu
bieten ich habe hier random wieder irgendwelche
zeug aufgemacht was halbwegs interessant geklungen hat wir gucken uns als
erst wir gucken uns eine runde semper video an
gucken was er was er zu erzählen hat zu telekom und wo davon haben jetzt
internets filter was ist eigentlich aus dem baum geworden noch nix
gezeigt wie filternet funktioniert internet ist ein gefiltertes internet von
telekom und wo davon und einigen anderen provide und wie die filterung von
statten geht das soll jetzt hier vereinfacht dargestellt werden
moment das ist das ist doch der erzählt jetzt irgendwas die über dns oder dns
filter ist ist resident sleeper das müssen wir uns nicht angucken
seite außerhalb
ja das ist das ist dns filter dass das das muss uns nicht angucken das ist nicht
sonderlich spannend ok skip skip gucken wir uns das nächste an open world sind
doof und niemand braucht sie ok paint gemp games da video aber ich finde das
titel der titel klang ich nicht und ich glaube es ist von moris moris gucke ich
immer gern das ist besser chain law telekom das haben wir doch schon
geguckt das andere
technik technik keller ist cool da guckst du aber auch nicht alles an
die hatten ein super video gemacht über seine ausbildung da als kfz fragt mich
nicht techniker wo er abgebrochen hat ins fisi fisi lernt ok gucken wir mal also
das scheint ein kontroverses thema zu sein 11k versus 1,4 bei dabei habt ihr
mitbekommen dass youtube sich überlegt hat darum runter abzuschaffen
richtig fehl wie willst du dann erklärt wie willst du dann erkennen ob
irgendwas sagt bevor du es guckst ja
ich hoffe die machen das nicht sie haben wir sich wieder raus geredet mit so nach
dem motto sie wollen einen sie wollen nicht negativität promoten und bla bla
bla also das übliche bullshit gelaber wenn man das aus anderen gründen macht
aber was anderes vorschiebt die wollen das in wirklichkeit abschaffen dass du
nicht von anfang an erkennst dass clickbait clickbait ist
so also jetzt jetzt gucken was was moris zu sagen hat
exzellent die lautstärke stimmt glaub schon open word sind doof und niemand
braucht sie ja stimme ich zu nächstes video mit niemand meine ich in dem fall
mich okay mit der drei war gut und meine meinung natürlich die einzig
allgemeingültige ist mir ist natürlich bewusst ich kämpfe damit ein wenig gegen
windmühlen open world sind ja kein neuer trend mehr keine mode erscheinung oder
sowas die sind fest im gaming angekommen moris moris ist der beste
games da ja sehe ich auch so ein essenzieller bestandteil einiger der
erfolgreichsten spiele aller zeit trotzdem finde ich viel weniger spiele
brauchen wirklich eine hat er recht als eine kriegen und oft ist eine open world
unterm strich doch nicht unbedingt die beste idee und habe ich ihm recht auf die
nerven und aber jetzt sage ich seit jahren auch schon hat er voll und ganz
recht will ich euch in diesem video mal darlegen und weil ich wie gesagt schon
jetzt den widerspruch mir entgegen hallen höre will ich mal mit ganz
objektiven faktischen zahlen anfangen und damit ghost of tsushima das hat
neulich schlagzeilen damit gemacht das ist tatsächlich eins der beiden meist
durchgespielten open world spiele auf der playstation ist zusammen mit
spider-man und zwar beide wurde von der hälfte aller spieler nur durchgespielt
das ist damit sind das ist ultra viel das ist also 50 prozent haben es durch
gespielt ist mega viel die meisten leute geben bei spielen irgendwie nach den
ersten zwei lefeln auf schon sagt rekordhalter das ist die spitze darunter
liegen spiele wie witcher 3 horizon zero dawn und red dead 2 die spiele die
allgemein als mit die größten open world meisterwerke der letzten jahre gelten
und die wurden alle nur von einem drittel der spieler durchgespielt noch
weiter unten liegt dann sowas wie assassin's creed wahlhalla wo man auch
sagen muss ja gut dass man dass man den langweiligen
grind nicht durchspielen will kann ich verstehen aber das wurde bislang nur von
20 prozent aller spieler durchgespielt das zeigt auch für nicht ein wenig dass
diese open world vielen spielern vielleicht tatsächlich ein wenig zu
groß sind und nicht nicht ich glaube ich glaube es liegt gar nicht so sehr an der
größe es liegt eher an diesem wir müssen es unbedingt voll stopfen mit 30
milliarden collectibles und was permanent das gefühl du verpasst was
aber auf der anderen seite ist es ultra langweilig dadurch also breath of the
wild finde ich hat das wirklich gut gemacht man kann über nintendo viel
sagen aber sowas können sie echt das war eine interessante spielwelt die sich
die sich selbst getragen hat mit vielen sachen die es zu entdecken gab die aber
nicht so so generic gewirkt haben ja nicht so nach dem motto da ist die 5778
zu truhe die ich aufmache wo eh nichts interessantes drin ist also es gab
schon es gibt da durchaus beispiele wo das gut funktioniert aber ubisoft
übertreibt sie letzten jahre mit assassin's creed schon maßlos mit da
gibt es flaggen zu sammeln da gibt es tauben zu sammeln da gibt es
schatzkisten zu sammeln da kannst du kannst du sachen sammeln nur wenn sie
mit deinem ubisoft account verknüpft sind dann hast du irgendwelche punkte die
du sammeln kannst da hast du da engen skill tree dann hast du da irgendwelche
aussichtspunkte dann hast du noch irgendwelche unlocks dann hast du noch
irgendwelche kostüme dann hast du noch irgendwelche in game händler quests und
bla bla bla da kannst du deine eigene mannschaft rekrutieren dann kannst du
hier mal ganz abgründen die übertreiben total die net die bauen einfach eine
welt das können die wirklich gut muss man ihm sagen also ich finde die
spielwelt von assassin's creed ist immer gut gemacht und danach stopfen sie die
einfach nur mit mit mit generic zeug voll ohne dass es irgendwie wahnsinnig
guten innen war guter inhalt ist naja weiter denn ich finde spiele können die
größe ihrer eigenen open world oft gar nicht tragen ja die spielmechanik
fesselt nicht so lange wie man eigentlich bräuchte um alles in der
welt zu sehen sie erschöpft sich bevor ich alles entdeckt habe mir geht es bei
assassin's creed sehr oft so zum beispiel assassin's creed origins hatte
ich das ganz stark dass ich die welt sogar ziemlich cool fand die war ein
sehr schön nachgebautes ägypten es gab durchaus auch einige nette quests und
sowas zu entdecken aber die spielmechanik hatte für mich nicht den
tiefgang und hat sich nicht so massiv weiterentwickelt im lauf all dieser
zeit und die sachen die ich getan habe haben sich nicht so weiterentwickelt und
so geändert dass ich wirklich die ganze zeit spaß hatte jetzt noch eine stadt
und noch eine stadt und hier noch eine nebenquest und so längst bevor ich das
ende der spielwelt erreicht hatte hatte ich schon das ende der faszination mit
der spielmechanik erreicht weil der spielaspekt auch einfach nicht tief
genug war dass der mich so lang bei der stange gehalten hätte wie die welt es
eigentlich gebraucht hätte oder zukommt dass entwickler ihre große welt auch
oft meiner meinung nach längst nicht bis zum rand mit wirklich guten wertvollen
inhalt ja ja vielleicht weil sie keine zeit dafür haben vielleicht fehlen auch
die idee dafür haben oder auch einfach weil sie nicht genügend gute idee
genau die kunst spannende quests zu bauen und je größer die welt wird desto
schwieriger ist es dass jede quest darin auch spannend bleibt das beste
beispiel dafür ist meiner meinung nach bioware deren spiele bio wahre unterm
strich eigentlich immer schlechter wurden je größer sie wurden bioware
quasi sowas wie ein komposthaufen mittlerweile noch als wäre es gestern
gewesen als sie lauthals damit geprallt haben dass ich ich wette mit euch er
bringt jetzt ich würde feiern wenn das wenn das bringt dass er wieder was zu
ente sagt und der bob dillen der videospiele das sagt er immer gerne und ich
finde das immer geil weil ich total übertrieben haben wieder in dragon age
inquisition so groß ist wie ganz origins aber origins war halt das viel besser
don't cry so much dankeschön für den sub inquisition größer ist wenn seine
welt und vor allem sein erstes gebiet die hinterlande heute allgemein als
synonym für eine aufgeblasene welt mit viel zu wenig spannenden inhalten gelten
und bei ob er hat überhaupt nicht was gelernt die haben es danach einfach
noch mal gemacht danach haben sie gesagt guckt mal mass effect andromeda da ist
ein planet so groß wie ganz inquisition und das spiel war auch wieder nur
schlechter also bei wo er hat überhaupt nicht geschafft diese großen welten
jetzt noch keine vollständigen open world waren muss man dazu sagen es waren
immer abgegrenzte gebiete aber schon sehr große weitläufige die klaren open
world charakter hatten sie haben es überhaupt nicht geschafft die zu füllen
und haben das spiel nicht besser dadurch gemacht dass es einfach groß war
ja genau klar ich habe dann freiheit überall hinzugehen aber wozu aber das
bringt mir ja nichts wenn es gar nicht so viel spannendes zu entdecken gab
mir ist natürlich bewusst man muss ja in einer open world nicht alles machen ich
muss nicht jede lahmen nebenquest erfüllen das ist ja sogar der punkt der
freiheit einer open world aber ich als spieler und ich glaube da geht es
psychologisch sehr vielen spielern so denn wir sind ja sammler und komplett
gibt bestimmt genug leute die mass effect nur wegen alien gachi bass
gespielt haben
hier in unserer natur ich hasse das gefühl im spiel etwas verpasst zu haben
ich weiß ja vorher nicht welche quest dann doch die spannenden sind und welche
die sind die links liegen lassen sollte deswegen will ich doch alles erleben
was das spiel zu bieten hat und will jeden quest marke abarbeiten dem ich in
so einer welt begegnen dass das sehe ich anders das sehe ich anders und ich
glaube das liegt unter anderem da unter anderem gerade an so spieler wie halter
was habe ich jetzt im hals er
das liegt unter anderem gerade an an an spielen wie assassin's creed die ein mit
mit content der langweilig ist zu scheißen ich skippe mittlerweile
absichtlich quests in games ich habe früher auch alles abgearbeitet das
problem ist aber gerade wenn das wenn das in single player rpg ist vor allem
auf die klassische art und weise mit erfahrungspunkten so wenn du jede quest
machst ist das spiel einfach übels easy mode es sei denn sie machen sind
skyrim mit level scaling oder sowas wenn du jede quest machst ist das spiel
absolut easy mode und außerdem sind die meisten quests auch langweilig also ich
lasse mittlerweile wirklich absichtlich quests links liegen und muss dann eben
oft feststellen dass halt viele davon aber meine zeit am ende nicht wert
gewesen wären und ich finde es ist die verantwortlichkeit der entwickler
dabei und und auch eine sache was ich jetzt mal was ich jetzt mal wieder los
mehr los was ich auch was ich auch wie zwiegespalten sehe von von der
entwicklung durch diese riesige masse an quests ja also nach dem motto die leute
haben zu klein zu wenig aufmerksamkeit spannen die schalten das game aus wenn
sie mal zwei minuten rumlaufen ohne dass was passiert sorgt es halt auch dafür
dass die spielwelt irgendwie nicht so authentisch ist oder für mich dass die
spielwelt eigentlich schon quasi nervig ist wenn ich keine zwei meter mal durch
ein gebiet laufen kann ohne dass nicht irgendwo in den quest marker oder sonst
was auf meiner minimap auf pop muss muss ja muss das muss eigentlich gar nicht
sein ich bin press of the white hat das echt ganz gut gezeigt dass man auch
mal eine spielwelt machen kann die die für sich stimmig ist und wo es auch
viele interessante sachen zu entdecken gibt und ja genau was sagen wollte eine
sache die mir echt auf den keks geht ist dass dadurch niemand mehr so wirklich
sich mit der spielwelt beschäftigen muss die leute rennen einfach ich muss ich
muss jetzt mal woanders ich will ich dass moris mich die ganze zeit anguckt wir
waren bei 5 30 dass man sich kaum noch mit der kaum noch mit der spielwelt
richtig beschäftigen muss und zwar dadurch dass man immer von quest marker
zu quest marker rennt und bei jeder quest dann auch noch einen feil oben hat
der einem zeigt wo man hin rennen muss das sorgt dafür dass man absolut keine
ahnung mehr hat von der spielwelt ich weiß nicht ob ihr ob ihr auch schon mal
die erfahrung gemacht habt zwischen dem spiel mit quest markern und im spiel
was vielleicht nur den quest marker oder gar kein quest marker macht oder wir
können es beispielsweise mit mit mmos vergleichen mit wo du von quest habt zu
quest abläuft oder mit mmos die vielleicht ein bisschen mehr pvp
orientiert sind oder sonst was also ich ich bin der meinung die spiele die nicht
so heavy focus auf an jeder ecke quest und an jeder ecke quest marker setzen du
kennst die spielwelt besser du kennst die spielwelt einfach besser du kannst
beispielsweise in der spielwelt navigieren ohne permanent auf die map
zu gucken und sobald du hast du schon mal witcher 3 spiel ja witcher 3 waren da
haben sie es gut getroffen mit der open world finde ich und bei anderen bei
anderen sachen hast du das problem wenn du permanent quest markern nachläufst
dann für dich sieht die spielwelt überall gleich aus weil du gar nicht
guckst weil du einfach nur quest markern nachläuft das merkt man zum
beispiel daran wenn man in der stadt ist die ein bisschen verwinkelt ist man
findet niemand man findet immer den ausgang nicht warum findet man den
ausgang nicht mehr weil man immer seinen quest marker nachläuft anstatt
quasi ich weiß ich kenne mich in der stadt aus ich weiß wo der ausgang ist du
rennt immer fack wo ging es hier jetzt raus wo ging es hier jetzt raus oder wo
geht es hier in die stadt rein wie auch immer einfach nur weil du dir das weil du
dir die welt nicht mehr anschaut sondern einfach nur stumpf quest marker
nachläufst
und witcher 3 fand ich insofern ganz gut weil witcher 3 eine super story hatte
und man die open world eher so als ramen hatte klar man konnte viel machen und
die war eigentlich an sich auch cool gemacht ich habe bei witcher 3 auch
nicht alle nebenquests gemacht aber die main story war im endeffekt das was
witcher 3 auch gestrahlt getragen hat
und ich finde sogar im hinblick auf dass ich weiß nicht ob die beste lösung ist
zu sagen man baut eine option ein um die minimap auszuschalten weil es ist halt
auch die frage wie man die welt designed wenn man eine welt baut die auf quest
markern nach laufen bedacht ist die ist vom design her sicherlich komplett
anders als eine spielwelt die darauf designed wurde erkennbare land marker zu
haben also sprich wenn ich also mal angenommen ich wäre jetzt game
entwickler und ich müsste eine welt design die quasi quest quest heavy ist
und ich wüsste die leute rennen hirnlos den quest marker nach dann würde ich
die welt so machen dass die leute möglichst easy von a nach b kommen das
heißt da dürfen jetzt auch nicht unüberwindbare hindernisse oder
sonstige sachen dazwischen sein sondern ok ich würde die welt im hinblick
ungefähr auf das machen so ein bisschen wie das in assassin's creed ist du
kannst überall drüber klettern du kannst überall drauf du kommst überall
easy hin das ist quasi eine spielwelt für wir
rennen quest markern und sachen auf der map nach wohingegen sagen wir mal die
breath of the wild map oder auch mmo maps oder die map von von gothic zum
beispiel genau das sind maps da auf denen kennst du dich aus weil über die map
navigierst du nicht von quest marker zu quest marker oder von minimap zu minimap
eintrag über die map navigierst du weil vielleicht irgendeinen npc gesagt hat
hinter dem wald ist am rechten berg ein banditen lager mit einem geheimen
schatz oder sowas und dann guckst du ok wie komme ich da hin wie geht es hier
durch den wald auf fack die gegner sind viel zu high level
ich level erstmal ein bisschen oder ich schleich mich durch oder was auch immer
und das sind ereignisse die merkst du dir das hast du auf fack das ist die ecke
mit den high level mobs und da ist die ecke wo die wo die leiter ist wo es den
berg hoch geht und hier ist auch der weg zurück ins lager und sowas in der
richtung das merkst du dir dann einfach und das ist das ist bei quest marker
nach renn spiele nicht der fall deswegen finde ich den ansatz option zu
machen gar nicht mal so einfach weil du die sein wahrscheinlich deine deine
spielumgebung komplett unterschiedlich für den für für beide unterschiedliche
sorten von games das heißt eine spielwelt die darauf designed ist dass
leute hier los quests aber arbeiten können funktioniert wahrscheinlich
ohne minimap gar nicht
und was natürlich dazu kommt das ist ja auch so ein bisschen witz eigentlich
müssen die quests und die hersteller sicher auch mehr anstrengen für den
content wenn es wenn es eine spiel ist wo man nicht von minimap punkt zu
minimap punkt von quest marker zu quest marker rennt weil dann muss man
erstens interessante quests machen wo die leute sagen da wird die will ich auch
machen ist ein bisschen anstrengender und du musst dafür sorgen dass die quests
so geschrieben sind und so aufgebaut sind dass man sie auch gut finden kann
also sprich du musst dir wirklich gedanken darüber machen du musst
vielleicht auch mal hinweise bei anderen npcs einbauen wo du fragen kannst wo
habt ihr das letzte mal wurde hier jemand von banditen überfallen und
sagen ja ja da hinten da hinten also sprich das erfordert viel mehr
fingerspitzengefühl bei den entwicklern so was zu machen als einfach nur von
quest marker zu quest marker zu rennen und dementsprechend kann man mit solchen
sachen auch gar nicht eine welt in jedem zentimeter vollkleistern
ich finde das hat man in witchart 3 ganz gut gesehen
witchart 3 hatte viele ziemlich gute quests auch ein paar auch ein paar wir
rennen einfach nur sinnlos rumquest aber in der regel waren eigentlich die
witchart 3 quests alle relativ gut und die gab es auch nicht alle alle zwei
zentimeter also das war schon mal da hat man schon den
unterschied erkannt
was gute quests ausmachen und ich ich hätte es auch cool gefunden wenn die
welt noch ein bisschen mehr sich bei witchart 3 in die richtung gegangen
wäre ich navigiere da ohne ohne ohne minimap und und ohne quest marker und so
was aber das haben sie ja teilweise gemacht mit du musst in dieses gebiet
und dann musst du selber finden wo es weitergeht das war so war so ein
kompromiss das kann euch ich kann euch heute
beispielsweise um jetzt mal ein beispiel aus dem mmo zu bringen ihr wisst ich
habe früher viel dark edge of camelot gekreidet und da war jetzt die die
spielwelt war jetzt vielleicht nicht mit irgendwie ich habe keine ahnung wie
groß das dragon age inquisition war was er im video gebracht hat die spielwelt
war vielleicht nicht mit modernen mmos mit 20 millionen add-ons zu vergleichen
aber die spielwelt dadurch dass es drei verschiedene reiche gab und ich habe in
allen drei gespielt über die jahre war die auch relativ groß und ich kann euch
heute noch genau sagen wo man irgendwo hinkommt also wenn mich da jetzt
irgendjemand fragt hier ohne map ohne ohne irgendwie sonst was ich konnte
einfach nach optischen sachen auf der map zu zu gewissen dungeons und sonst
was navigieren und das liegt einfach daran weil ich in der spielwelt war und
ich mir die angucken musste ich bin gar nicht drumherum gekommen und
dementsprechend hat man sich das auch gemerkt und das finde ich immer noch
cool heute wenn ich manchmal in das game noch ein logge oftmals auf einem free
chart dann laufe ich teilweise ganz gerne einfach mal random so durch die
welt und denken wir so ha cool guck mal ich kann mich auch daran erinnern hier
haben wir mal früher gelevelt und sowas in der richtung ist eigentlich richtig
cool weil man weil man persönlich viel viel involvierter oder so mehr
investiert quasi in der welt ist ja genau es wird mal wieder zeit für ein
ordentliches early access survival game hey ich habe gehört der dayz typ der
dayz typ hat jetzt ein komisches neues early access survival game ob das jemals
fertig wird steht auf dem anderen platte also leute ok aber weiter eigentlich
könnte ich diese eigentlich könnte ich das doch jetzt kurz hochladen mit max
reacted auf youtube max reacted auf games darstellt so was mache ich denn
hier auf das wollte ich gerade auf mal wohl ja gucken wir mal weiter also 530
sind wir stehen geblieben
meine zeit als spieler zu respektieren und mir nur inhalte zu bieten die meine
zeit wert sind die cool gemacht die spannend die was besonderes sind und
meiner voll und ganz recht damit man am ende sagen kann guck mal leute wir haben
100 stunden spielzeit und eine dreimal so große welt wie der vorgänger das ist
für mich nicht zielführend das macht kein besseres dankeschön für den zapp
größeres und längeres spiel ja und da hat er voll und ganz recht im prinzip
gleiche was ich auch gerade erzählt hat für mich persönlich kommt auch noch
dazu ich habe einfach nicht die zeit all diese 100 stunden monster zu spielen
selbst wenn sie das gut sind das ist richtig und ich habe auch gar kein bock
da drauf weil wenn der content im prinzip nur sich selbst recycelt also
wo ist der mehrwert für mich als spieler es gibt viel zu viele coole
spiele auf die ich bock hätte heutzutage jeder von uns hat ein viel zu großes
backlog auf steam als der z-typ das habe ich letztens erst irgendwo gelesen
der z-typ hat jetzt irgendeinen irgendeinen survival ding auf steam
gestartet irgendwas wo die leute in so
astronauten auszüge anzügen rumrennen ohne pvp genau ich glaube das haben wir
sogar letzte woche angeguckt ja
in könnte was man wollte und bei mir kommt noch dazu selbst ein starkes spiel
ein richtig gutes spiel wird mir manchmal nach 40 50 stunden oder so einfach
langweilig weil ich was andere singleplayer spiele ja das ist richtig
gerade singleplayer spiele mit dem gleichen ding verbringen will da bin ich
vielleicht auch bisschen zu was das game was du meinst ist schon zwei jahre
alt erarbeitet bereit am nächsten der typ hat ein talent dafür spiele aus dem
boden zu stampfen und nicht fertig zu machen oder wie oder was
anderen spielern anders gehen absolut aber ich persönlich spiele lieber
mehrere kurze intensive spannende spiele als 100 stunden in assassins spiel
wallhalla zu verbringen kommt auf das game an bewusst das ist ja bei
assassins spiel geben sie eben recht und b auch von der aktuellen
lebenssituation wenn jetzt zum beispiel noch in der schule seid dann habt ihr
wahrscheinlich deutlich mehr freizeit wir macht schon hausaufgaben aber weniger
geld und dann sind spiele die euch zum vollpreis 100 stunden 200 stunden open
word gameplay geben eine deutlich bessere investition weil sie hat ein
starkes preis-leistungsverhältnis haben im sinne von unterhaltsame stunden pro
ausgegebenem euro da ist das dann vielleicht sehr gut nachvollziehbar
dass man sich eher ein wallhalla kauft als ein so durchchoreografiertes story
spiel wie zum beispiel ein last of us das zwar ein sehr spannendes intensives
erlebnis bietet aber eben auch schneller wieder vorbei ist so dass man schneller
wieder geld in die hand nehmen muss wenn man weiter was zocken will das
da habe ich vollstes verständnis dafür also ich verstehe ich verstehe was er
meint ich gebe mir prinzipiell recht wobei ich sagen muss ich meine ich gehe
auch vier tage die woche arbeiten und macht ein bisschen youtube stellts
nebenbei und so also sprich ich gehe auch nicht mehr in die schule und habe
über übermäßig viel zeit trotzdem muss ich sagen ich wünsche mir
tatsächlich mal wieder ein spiel am besten also ein multiplayer mmo was sich
echt komplett am besten mit dem farbjahr zusammen was ich komplett
durchsucht könnte die nächsten drei jahre da hätte ich bock drauf wo ich
quasi lust hätte im endeffekt jede minute wo ich zeit habe online mit meinen
mit meinem 1 2 characters rumzustelzen aber da gibt es irgendwie nichts für
mich gerade
aber ich persönlich eben freue mich immer wenn ein spiel mal eher sagt du
musst hier nicht 100 stunden spielen wir geben dir 10 20 30 die dafür so richtig
finde ich auch gut ja das sind die spiele die mir oft da hat er
gedächtnis ja das stimmt das stimmt also spiele spiele die einem im
gedächtnis bleiben muss ich sagen es sind bei mir auch zum großen teil games
mit einer story die mich irgendwie so so abgeholt hat ja
und da sind oftmals auch gut natürlich in kombination mit spielen die wo man
sachen zum ersten mal gespielt für mich wird half life eins immer noch das
beste spiel aller Zeiten bleiben wobei man das halt sagen muss das ist nicht
in allen aspekten gut gealtert mir geht es aber nicht nur um die spielzeit
dabei denn open world steht auch grundlegender genau dem gegenüber was
ich eigentlich von spielen will denn ich erlebe am liebsten diese spannenden
intensiven durch inszenierten stories aber genau die sind in einer open world
aufgrund ihrer natur schwer zu erzählen man kann sich dazu vor laut vier
anschauen wo ich mein kind in der postapollipse
finden will eine unglaublich dringende mission ja eigentlich aber die spiel
dann erstmal däumchen drehen dass ich auch 100 stunden damit verbringen kann
mit preston garvis siedlungen zu retten und aufzubauen anstatt auch nur eine
sekunde nach meinem baby zu suchen weil natürlich die open world eines
Bethesda spiels gerade mit dieser freiheit ja glänzt das ist ihre stärke
aber gerade das steht diametral dem erzählen einer starken story gegenüber
und selbst spiele die eigentlich als story meister werden gegelten auch zu
recht haben dieses problem witcher 3 ist ja ganz ähnlich ja auch da suche ich
mein verlorenes kind in der noch dringender weil besagtes kind aktiv
bedroht wird und ich weiß das auch aber auch hier kann ich jeden unsinn in der
open world machen und das spiel rechtfertigt das nicht mal irgendwie
weil nie ein es ist nie ein story punkt habe ich mir nie gedanken darüber
gemacht hat er nicht ohne recht dass gerard nix zu essen hat zum beispiel und
so arm ist dass er ständig monster aufträge erfüllen muss nun überhaupt
über die runden zu kommen in den büchern in witcher büchern ist das
bisschen mehr so da hat er als hexa ein hartes leben aber in der spiel balance
von witcher 3 ertrink ich ja immer in gold und hat eigentlich nie ein problem
und kann trotzdem gewinnturniere spielen statt nach ziri zu suchen was für ein
quatsch witcher 3 hat andere stärken in sachen story also auch die hauptstory
ist toll aber sie leidet finde ich schon unter diesem open world problem das
macht sie weniger spannend und dringlich und intensiv als sie sein
könnte witcher 3 kompensiert das damit dass eins der wenigen open world spiele
ist wo auch die nebenquests ja durchweg genau habe ich ja vorhin auch gesagt
genau was bio wer nicht geschafft hat ja dass selbst die nebenaufgaben fast alle
interessant sind und wenn es nur mit einem kleinen detail ist ich sage auch
gar nicht dass es unmöglich ist eine gute open world story zu erzählen aber
es ist eben sehr schwierig selbst für sehr gute autoren weil open world die
freiheit will die hauptstory links liegen zu lassen während die meisten
klassischen geschichten genau das nicht wollen vorher der ringe der ring das
brauchen wir eigentlich nicht so wie wir müssen jetzt gerade overrated ring
overrated gebetet dabei helfen die ernte einzubringen wäre völliger schwach
sind hat jemand hat jemand von euch das herr der ring immermo gespielt
folgen hat in den büchern sage ich mal ein paar nebenquests wie tom bombadil
eingebaut die tatsächlich aber auch natürlich ein bisschen das pacing
rausgenommen haben aus der story und für den film dann gestrichen wurden
während eine story die zu einer open world passt müsste eine andere struktur
haben die müsste irgendwie berücksichtigen und auch begründen
warum die hauptfigur vielleicht nicht warum warum der open world umstellt
ich finde das geht auch cyberpunk hatte da ein bisschen ein ansatz in die
richtung den ich gar nicht blöd fand dass es manchmal in der story einfach
nachvollziehbare gründe gab warum wie jetzt mal ein wenig söldnerarbeit
erledigen muss weil du geld brauchst um weiterzukommen weil ein questgeber
den ich hilf bis du ihn ordentlich schmierst und auch weil die von der
story her ja wirklich gegen einen feind kämpfen muss der ihm so überlegen
ist ich bin immer noch überlegen ob ich mir das holen soll kann man das
mittlerweile halbwegs spielen dass es sinn ergibt dass du in dieser welt auch in
dieser knallharten jetzt mal ein bisschen dich aufrüsten muss und da halt
irgendwie geld verdienen muss auch da bei ich das hat irgendwann aus weil du
kannst auch sagen ich verdiene jetzt aber erstmal mal geld für mein fünftes
luxusauto dann ist es wieder 20 euro ja das konstrukt ist zumindest verbindet ein
bisschen besser story dringlichkeit mit open world freiheit aber selbst hier
knarzt es eben irgendwo und deswegen finde ich es immer ein wenig schade
wenn spiele in open world richtung gehen dies in meinen augen gar nicht bräuchten
zum beispiel life is strange jetzt das ist doch ein parade beispiel für eine
sehr story fokussierte serie die in meinen augens absolut nicht nötig hätte
und sich sogar schaden könnte damit eine open world aufzubauen
weil das doch genau entgegen dem steht wofür die serie bislang stand wobei life
is strange es könnte auch passen weil life is strange doch auch immer einen
recht entspannten charakter irgendwo zusätzlich hatte und da könnte man eine
story schreiben wo es passt dass ich auch nebenbei immer wieder die open world
erkunde und kleinere nebengeschichten aber es muss ja nicht es muss ja gar
nicht unbedingt jedes spiel auf teufel komm raus open world haben gab jetzt ja
genug sachen wo es in die hose gegangen ist oder zumindest wurden dann auch
immer wo es irgendwie angepflanzcht gewirkt hat und es hätte nicht mehr
gepasst dass ich einfach irgendwie jetzt mal hier komplett abschweife von der
hauptgeschichte also da müssen sie auch was am story modell ändern dass sie
verfolgen deswegen ich hoffe sie kriegen das hin aber es macht mir eben ein wenig
sorgen es macht mir mehr sorgen dass ich mich darauf freue wenn ich höre live
strange kriegt eine open world es ist aber natürlich trotzdem auch möglich wie
bereits gesagt tolle stories in open world zu erzählen ich höre euch schon
alle red dead redemption 2 schreien natürlich können open world auch tolle
geschichten erzählen es ist halt aber in meinen augen eher die ausnahme als die
regel und es sind ja ausnahme spiele die das schaffen es braucht wirkliche
ausnahme entwickler um diesen spagat diesen kompromiss hinzukriegen und
deswegen bin ich eben der meinung open world im zweifelsfall lasst doch auch
einfach mal sein ja aber wie gesagt das ist nur meine
meinung auch wenn wie gesagt reingangs hier in diese ich sehe das ganz ähnlich
aber sagt mir gern ob ich euch zumindest ein wenig überzeugen könnte
findet ihr open also er muss mich da nicht überzeugen ich habe das schon
ähnlich gesehen von komplett doof fanden diese davor vielleicht schon doof oder
rede ich hier nur schwachsinn und open world ist das beste was dem gaming je
passieren konnte und ich rede hier nur was wie das beste was dem gaming je
passieren konnte alter playstation for life scheiß wixbox schreibt es mir
gerne was eure liebsten open world playstation beste mal auch problemen mit
open world sind die ihr mal hatte serien wo ihr dachtet ach eigentlich nicht so
toll dass das jetzt open world geworden ist hätte eigentlich nicht gebraucht
wobei ich gebe zu konsolen konsolen flame war es auch das sagt das steigt
keiner mehr darauf ein ansonsten haben wir auch noch videos von den lieben ich
habe noch nicht über eine aktuelle playstation und eine aktuelle xbox
stehen als ich schaut euch die gerne mal an und wir haben auch ein
streitgespräch wo beide seiten vertreten sind also jenes macht immer
gute videos wobei doch ich habe die aktuelle playstation weil die aktuelle
ist ja eigentlich noch die 4er weil die 5er ist ja nicht lieferbar
näh ich glaube ich habe die letzten jahre seit der letzten konsolengeneration
kaum noch kaum noch konsole gespielt
excellent so was gucken wir uns jetzt an warum das deutsche schulsystem in der
krise versagt ok wetnet übertreibt es wieder total dogecoin kurs alda doge
dogecoin dogecoin kurs wie ist der dogecoin kurs so
dogecoin allah bärm
so gekollt
ok schauen wir mal
ok stimmt ihr habt recht es sind zwei aber ich höre es ja gleich an der Stimme
das teilweise immer echt ist äußerst dramatisch formuliert in den videos
genau das ist er der formulierte übelst dramatisch die schulen müssen schließen
die pandemie lässt ihnen keine andere wahl schule soll ab jetzt online stattfinden in
form von homeschooling und hier beginnt die pandemie ist am start trifft das
schulsystem wie miley cyrus abrissbirne
tos tos
die auswirkungen der pandemie haben zwei massive probleme entblößt die unsere schulen nicht erst
seit 2020 plagen sondern seit jahrzehnten heute geht es darum warum das deutsche schulsystem in
der krise versagt hat und wie es jetzt weitergeht also ich glaube das problem was wir generell haben
wenn es um so anpassungsfähigkeit geht ist dass wir so übertrieben bürokratisch in vielen an
vielen kritischen stellen sind ja wohingegen man manchmal eben anpassungsfähig sein muss und auch
schnell auf stinger reagieren muss machen wir erst mal ein halbes jahr rum und schicken uns und
schicken uns die ergebnisse noch irgendwie perfekt die digitalisierung der schulen hat
viele vorteile smart boards oder lernprogramme auf tablets und laptops können modernen effektiven
und das ist aber auch eine vorstellung von der schulklasse die die irgendwie nicht so
ganz mit der realität zu tun okay weiter was machen die da überhaupt
das sieht aus wie eine nord red workflow ist das nord red workflow kann ja eigentlich nicht
sein was gucken die sich da an schüler können leichter individuell fortschritte machen und
gefördert werden gleichzeitig lernen sie den umgang mit digitalen medien allein schon dass
es eine klasse ist wo nur zehn leute drin sitzen ist ja schon mal komplett fernabwiegliche realität
bei uns scratch kenne ich nicht bei uns sind die klassen eher mit 30 leuten voll sodass keiner
mehr durchblickt was eigentlich abgeht und der schulalltag wird vereinfacht lehrer müssen bei
all dem natürlich in der lage sein die technik vernünftig zu nutzen am ersten montag nach
sie leise oder meldet das bayerische kultusministerium passt eigentlich hätten die server der
lernplattform mehbe ist lahmgelegt naja exklusiv musik nur die schüler und lehrer die versucht haben das system zu nutzen
auch im rest deutschlands crashen die lernplattformen arbeitsblätter werden per e-mail
verschickt per fax hey ich warte immer noch bis ich das per fax kriege schüler einmal die woche per
telefon zu erreichen millionen schülerinnen und schüler sitzen eingepfercht zu hause häufig ohne
laptops oder tablets und versuchen irgendwie mitzukommen die frustration bei den familien
ist riesig oft ist zu wenig platz es gibt zu viele geschwister die eltern müssen selber arbeiten
und können nicht bei den aufgaben helfen diese wochen bedeuten anschluss verlieren abschluss
nicht schaffen stillstand anzeige es raus irgendwann im frühling und die schulen werden langsam wieder
geöffnet viele schüler müssen also ich persönlich habe damit keine probleme ihr wisst dass ich das
super finde also nicht korona an sich sondern einige maßnahmen die daraus resultieren wie
zum beispiel dauer home office besser können es eigentlich nicht sein und dass ich durch die ganze
sache wahrscheinlich auch home office breiter in deutschland durchsetzen wird finde ich auch
eine super geschichte also kommt immer drauf an ja doch überbrücken vor allem diejenigen die auch schon vor
der pandemie nicht mitgekommen sind was sagen deine kollegen mit kindern dass ich das ich weiß das
nur von einem dem gibt dem geht dem geht das richtig auf den sack da kommt teilweise lieber in die
firma dass er seine ruhe hat ja ja also es ist schon abhängig davon was man so für private
situation hat ja die bundesregierung hat bereits 2016 den digitalpakt schule vorgestellt 5,5
jahre sollten für die digitalisierung der schulen bereitgestellt werden für geräte
lernplattformen et cetera leider sind bis Mitte 2020 nur fünf prozent des gelbes bewilligt dieses
geld kann also ich sag doch wir machen es gerne unglaublich bürokratisch nur 0,3 prozent ist ja
fast ist ja fast wie bei der korona hilfe wenn du nicht gerade irgendwie große automobil konzern
bis kriegst du nix oder oder kommt halt sehr sehr sehr sehr verzögert an an gekommen sieben
bundesländer haben zu diesem zeitpunkt noch keinen einzigen euro erhalten im december werden die
schulen nach etwas hin und her wieder geschlossen elf millionen schülerinnen und schüler sitzen
wieder zu hause dieses mal läuft zum glück einiges besser der digitale kollege von mir hat
gerade eine tochter in kolumbien und die machen seit anfang an seit korona losgegangen ist machen
die unterricht remote und die kriegen das auch gebacken cool war es dankeschön für den sub
klappt an vielen schulen zumindest halbwegs bis ende 2020 wurden rund 25 prozent der original
summe aus dem digitalpakt bewilligt und knapp 9 prozent sind angekommen das gesamtpaket wurde
auf 7,15 milliarden euro aufgestockt ja das bringt jetzt erstmal unmittelbar nichts viele
schüler haben allerdings immer noch keine tablets oder laptops lernplattformen sollen immer noch
zurückhaltend genutzt werden weil sie sonst wieder gehackt zusammenbrechen für viele schüler war
2020 im prinzip ein verlorenes jahr wie je nachdem wenn es eh nicht wenn es nicht gerade er muss
ja nicht übertreiben wenn es jetzt nicht gerade ein jahrgang ist wo du dein abi machst oder ein
abschluss dann ist das behaupte ich jetzt einfach mal nicht so krass und es soweit kommt exiu ex iu
1 ich weiß nicht wie man es richtig ausbauen dankeschön für den sub auf jeden fall jexiu
die pandemie hat überrumpelt gar keine frage und natürlich leidet der unterricht darunter das ist
unvermeidbar aber das deutsche schulsystem war so richtig schlecht vorbereitet 2000 ist ja auch
kein wunder wenn da heute noch video recorder und overhead projektoren benutzt werden und
18 hat eine studie untersucht wie es im internationalen vergleich in sachen digitalisierung
abschneidet und naja das deutsche system war in fast jeder hinsicht unterdurchschnittlich
entwickelt besonders im vergleich zu dänemark deutlich die den geben für so was ja ordentlich
geld aus der schüler an dass sie die den bezahlt bezahlen übrigens auch ziemlich viel steuern aber
die machen damit auch was habe ich den eindruck digitale medien im unterricht nutzen würden in
dänemark waren es 91 prozent hier hatte jede vierte schule stabiles wlan in dänemark jede
in deutschland nutzten 17 prozent der schüler und leber eine lernplatte was zum teufel ist das in
dänemark 97 prozent das erste digitale investitionsprogramm startete so schlecht
vor 20 jahren bis ich dann schon drei monate 2001 für den umgang mit digitalen ja 2001 da haben
die leute sich noch überlegt wenn es die nächsten faxgeräte gibt inzwischen wird dort seit langem
alles digital geregelt noten fehlzeiten hausaufgaben termin kalender gut dänemark ist auch absolute
spitzenklasse in dieser hinsicht aber der unterschied zu deutschen schulen ist dennoch bemerkenswert
bildung ist in deutschland ländersache die 16 schulministerinnen und minister stimmen ihre
schulpolitik auf der sogenannten kultusminister ja striker 95 das ist ja das das ist ja das was
mich immer nervt wenn ich sehe wie viel wie viel anteilmäßig von steuern von der kohle
weggeht und wie wenig mit dem damit gemacht wird und offensichtlich dort ankommt was mir wichtig
ist deswegen nervt es mich das ja auch immer wenn ich teuer bezahlen muss ich sollte ich sollte
einfach noch ein paar millionen machen und dann nach luxemburg gehen wie amazon easy und die
rechtlichen rahmen die kommunen bezahlen den rest vom schulhaus über lehrbücher bis hin zur
digitalausstattung das heißt je nachdem wie reich eine kommune ist desto besser oder schlechter
können die schulen vor ort finanziert werden in einzelnen reichen gemeinden gibt es deshalb
digitale vorzeigeschulen ärmere kommunen mit geringen steuereinnahmen oder personalmangel
konnten ihre schulen über jahre allerdings nicht entsprechend ausstattet wo du wohnst bestimmt in
deutschland also leider häufig ob es an deiner schule smart boards ja oder oder mich nicht ja
ja ja ja es gibt bestimmt viele schulprojektoren immer noch totalisierung der schulen bundesweit
vernünftig koordiniert und vorangetrieben erst 2016 15 jahre nach dänemark und 2016 2016 ist
schon ziemlich ziemlich modern alles ja da ist hat die gesamte welt schon ausgebaut und wir kommen
jetzt auf die idee vielleicht sollte man mal was machen regierung den digitalpakt schule ins leben
gerufen der bund durfte die länder aber eigentlich gar nicht auf diese weise finanziell unterstützen
das grundgesetz wurde 2019 deshalb extra angepasst erst dann konnte das geld endlich fließen aber es
fließt bisher nur sehr sehr langsam der hauptgrund dafür sind wohl äußerst hohe bürokratische
hürden ja jeder einzelne können wir unglaublich gut zum beispiel zunächst einen komplexen
medienentwicklungsplan mit sehr hohen anforderungen ausarbeiten und bei den kommunen einreichen erst
wenn diese pläne bewilligt sind gibt es geld dann kam der lockdown und der gigantische rückstand des
deutschen schulsystems hat sich gerecht viele schulen hatten keine geräte keine digitale
infrastruktur keine entsprechend geschulten lehrer homeschooling das wundert halt kein das ist jetzt
dass es dann jetzt zuschlägt chaos und es gibt noch ein weiteres problem dass die fünf
milliarden nicht reichen das wusste von da war von vornherein klar dass das überhaupt auf
nichts kalkuliert war das war bestenfalls eine startinvestition und dann haben wir mal ausgerechnet
also eigentlich hätte diese finanzierung für deutschland 20 millionen davon abgesehen ist
er trotzdem nicht angekommen das sind harald willard und malis tepe der harald vorsitzender der
schulleitungsvereinigung nrw sie ist vorsitzende der größten lehrer und lehrerinnen gewerkschaft
deutschlands gew in der pandemie wurde der digitalpakt ja von fünfeinhalb auf insgesamt
rund sieben milliarden euro aufgestockt auf elf millionen schüler gerechnet sind das trotzdem
nur 650 euro pro schüler kann sie mit ipad kaufen malig die schulen brauchen aber fortlaufend geld
um die infrastruktur in betrieb zu halten it fachkräfte lizenzen gerätewartung fortbildungen
für lehrer nach ansicht von tepe und willard müsste eigentlich noch deutlich mehr investiert
werden mit geringeren hürden man darf ja auch nicht vergessen dass investition quasi in die
ausbildung in die schule auch irgendwie eine investition in die zukunft ist also das das tritt
alles immer nur mit mit mit größerer zeitverzögerung ein wenn man es darf verkackt ist das nicht
unmittelbar zu sehen sondern vielleicht erst in 20 30 jahren richtig und wenn man es da gut macht
ist es auch nicht unmittelbar zu sehen sondern vielleicht richtig auch erst in 20 30 jahren
deswegen tut man sich da wahrscheinlich auch so unglaublich schwer also generell tut sich ja
unsere politik sehr schwer damit visionäre sachen zu machen ja wo man sagt hey das ist wichtig das
müssen wir machen oder zumindest einen plan dafür haben der nicht einfach nur sagt bis 2040 machen
wir das sondern der ein plan hat der sagt so soll es da aussehen mit diesen zwischenschritten und
das kann man auch überprüfen und kontrollieren ja wir sind gut wir sind gut darin zu sagen bis 2045
wollen wir xy haben aber das wichtig ist man braucht einen plan wo nachvollziehbar ist wann wie wo
was gemacht wird dass es nicht einfach nur eine luftnummer ist sondern wo auch wirklich konkret
was was rauskommen soll und das ist ja unliebsam weil es kostet jetzt geld und man sieht es
vielleicht erst in in 10 15 20 30 jahren was bei manchen sachen rauskommen ist es natürlich
äußerst unbeliebt das möchte man natürlich nicht machen in deutschland sind schüler aus
wohlhabenden gebildeten familien besser in der schule als schüler aus ärmeren familien und
familien mit das wundert mich nicht diese chancen ungleich und umgekehrt wenn du im ghetto auf
wächst und auf eine kack schule gehst natürlich deine chancen nicht so hoch wie wenn du da auf
wächst in unserem schulsystem ist im internationalen vergleich besonders drastisch und was ich
witzig finde wenn ich sowas immer sehe was ich finde dass die leute immer noch der meinung sind
es ist es ist so geil ja es geht nicht darum was man auf dem papier im durchschnitt hat ja wenn
du wenn du das durchschnitt wenn du sagst ok wir nehmen jetzt einfach mal die aller ärmsten
alle reichsten zusammen und wir haben natürlich leute in deutschland die unglaublich viel geld
haben dann geht sieht das im durchschnitt gar nicht so schlecht aus aber das ist ja nicht die
realität von den leuten tagtäglich das ist auch nicht die realität an der schule irgendwo in
irgendeinem problembezirk in berlin oder so die haben ganz andere probleme und deswegen so geil
wie das wie das teilweise in den köpfen der leute ist ist das hier gar nicht es ist auch nicht so
dass hier jeder mega reich ist auch wenn das gerne so hingestellt wird es gibt so viel leute
die leben vorne da habe ich kenne ich auch genug beispiele die leben im endeffekt von
monatsgehalt zu monatsgehalt und haben am ende des monats obwohl die 40 stunden die woche
arbeiten gehen minus auf dem konto dass das kann es einfach nicht sein gut ich meine wir
beschäftigen uns ja mit essentiellen problemen lieber mit irgendwelchen vorgeschobenen moral
diskussionen wo sich alle daran beteiligen und wahnsinnig empören können über twitter ist
vielleicht auch ganz gut dass die leute erst gar nicht merken wie schlecht es ihnen eigentlich
geht angemessen an dem was eigentlich an geld da ist man darf nicht vergessen man sollte sich
nicht so sehr vergleichen mit uns geht es ja super gut weil keine ahnung wir nicht hungern
müssen oder ein dach überm kopf haben ich weiß nicht ob das der anspruch ist ich meine wir sind
die tritt viert viert größte glaube ich viert größte wirtschaft volkswirtschaft der welt in
deutschland ich weiß nicht ob unser anspruch sein sollte wir müssen nicht hungern und erfrieren
das ist glaube ich nicht so da vom verhältnis ja nicht so das wo wir anspruch daran haben sollten
und gerade ausbildung in der schule und von den kindern ist essentiell dafür dass es uns in 20
30 jahren immer noch gut geht cool system liegt japan forns ich glaube schon ich glaube es ist
usa usa china ja grüß genau usa china japan deutschland
die komodas sind auf dem aufsteigenden ast ja
so also wir sind die viertgrößte volkswirtschaft der welt das ist jetzt nicht dass man sagen kann ja
ja wir haben ja eigentlich kein geld oder sonst wo die frage ist nur was machst du mit dem geld
bekommt das hin und wenn man sich überlegt wie viel kohle wir eigentlich theoretisch haben und
da weiß ich nicht ob da ob der passende vergleich ist wir müssen ja nicht hungern und erfrieren
da sollte man da nicht ein bisschen höheren anspruch haben gerade an die ausbildung und
solche geschichten oder auch an infrastruktur ausbau an krank an gesundheitsversorgung und
sowas internationalen vergleich besonders drastisch der internationale vergleich zeigt ja sehr klar
dass man schanzen gleich schanzen gleichheit relativ gut herstellen kann also wenn wir zum
beispiel noch ich finde das übrigens auch unglaublich wichtige geschichte man kann sich
nicht auf der einen seite über parallelgesellschaften auf gegen dieser nur mich sagen muss man nach berlin
gucken man ist ja nur zweifelsfrei gibt aber das ist eines der besten wege dass so was sich
nicht auf jahre hält ja wenn du auch leute aus schwächeren schichten hast die in der
schule chancen gleichheit haben und später auch mal was erreichen können die kommen halt
dann auch auf so was raus generell ist es aber so durchschnittlicher wohlstand wohl dass das beste
mittel um gegen so was vorzubeugen ja dann muss dann muss da gibt es keine getto ist
mehr am frankfurter hauptbahnhof so also gerade das ist denke ich echt unglaublich wichtiges
thema wo es halt nicht nicht vorwärts geht wie gesagt overhead projektor und video recorder
ist noch am start schaun oder asien dort sind auch die kinder aus den sozial schwachen familien sehr
sehr gut in der schule das heißt kann man sehr viel mehr erreichen als deutschland das ist
ein bisschen china eigentlich erschossen wenn du schlecht in der schule bist er ist direktor
für bildung und kompetenzen bei der ich habe da kein problem wird dort die bekannten pisa
studien schüler aus nicht akademischen haushalten und familien mit migrationshintergrund haben es
im homeschooling am schwersten ihre eltern können ihnen häufig nicht unter die arme greifen oder
ihnen den raum und die ruhe bieten selbstständig zu lernen gerade diese schüler muss unser system
eigentlich auffangen und unterstützen die schüler dieser generationen haben einen lernverlust laut
andreas schleicher würden sie deshalb über ihr leben hinweg potenziell zwischen drei und vier
prozent weniger geld verdient da frage ich mir wie hat er das ausgerechnet der rechenweg wird mich
echt mal brennend interessieren und das kann sich auf die gesamtwirtschaft jetzt über wenigstens
das ausgerechnet mit tausenden 2000 3000 milliarden niederschlagen in der bilanz das ist ja schon
relativ konkrete zahl drei bis vier prozent erhebliche kosten es lässt sich natürlich schwer
sagen drei plus eins quickmaps der wirtschaftliche schaden tatsächlich so groß wird eine solche
kettenreaktion gibt dennoch zu denken gerade wenn in der wohnung wenig platz ist und die eltern
unter druck stehen leiden kinder unter seelischem stress auch das betrifft studien zufolge vor allem
die kinder deren eltern einen leute die zu lange vorm computer sitzen laufen auch immer so rum auch
wenn sie nicht gestresst sind bildungsabschluss oder einen migrationshintergrund haben es gibt
anzeichen dass diese kinder deutlich stärker durch die pandemie belastet werden sie weisen häufiger
psychosomatische beschwerden wie bauch oder kopfschmerzen auf außerdem erleben sie ausgeprägtere
symptome von angst und depression vielerorts wird versucht ihnen zu helfen der landtag in
nrw hat im juni 2020 zum beispiel 75 millionen euro bereitgestellt dieses geld sollte für
spezielle ferienangebote für abgehängte schüler genutzt werden bis februar 2021
wir sind so krass bürokratisch das ist der wahnsinn es ist ja auch bei infrastrukturausbau auch so
dass es wohl relativ relativ viel geld gibt aber es kommt einfach nicht wie soll man das in die
erde nur fünf millionen euro ab also in form von kadu infrastruktur es gibt viel kohle aber irgendwie
geht es nicht vorwärts gerufen worden die gelder sind ihn einfach in die kommunen gegeben worden
teilweise am vorletzten schultag teilweise am letzten schultag mit dem hinweis macht was draus
letztlich hätte ja gute lernplattformen macht was draus ist ja erstmal nicht verkehrt versierte
lehrer und ein kabel zu hause vielen benachteiligten schülern helfen können so hat sich die mangel der
digitalisierung in der pandemie umso mehr gerecht wenn sie aus einem sozial günstigen umfeld kommen
dann haben sie immer viele chancen im leben auch ohne gute schule wenn sie aus einem schwierigen
umfeld kommen dann haben sie eine einzige chance in ihrem leben und das ist eine gute schule
hat die schulpolitik versagt die versagt seit jahren nicht jetzt ist noch einmal ganz besonders
simone fleischmann die vorsitzende des bayerischen dort lehrer und lehrerinnenverband
formuliert das so es gibt schwachstellen im bildungssystem die jetzt wie mit einem spotlight
angeleuchtet werden ich sage immer es gibt schmuddelecken schmuddelecken der schulpolitik
wo wir dachten ich habe auch ich habe auch schmuddelecken bei mir und genau da ist jetzt
der scheinwerfer drauf kommen die konzentration nicht und nicht da wo ihr denkt nicht da wo ihr
denkt also muss ich jetzt vielleicht die schlimmste schmuddelecke bei mir im haus ist nicht etwa das
klo oder irgendwie sowas in der richtung wo man das vielleicht erwarten wird das ist eigentlich
relativ sauber die schlimmste schmuddelecken ist der dachboden alter da gehe ich unglaublich
ungern hin auf den dachboden dachboden ne das also der dachboden ist schmuddelecke
die hose die hose ist unten also zumindest dabei
passt du dir nicht umbauen der ist umgebaut aber ich gehe trotzdem nicht gerne unterfinanzierten
digitalisierung und üble nochmals befeuerte chancen ungleichheit das ist der dreck der jetzt
in aller hässlichkeit im scheinwerfer licht der alter der formuliert das immer so krass
dramatisch und ich hatte ja recht aber das ist immer so noch mal befeuerte chancen dramatisch
einfach nur das ist der dreck der jetzt in aller hässlichkeit im scheinwerfer licht liegt nachdem
corona in das system gecrashed ist aber in diesem system arbeiten letztlich menschen und wir ziehen
unseren hut vor nicht mal lang nicht mal lang die während der pandemie alles für ihre schüler
gegeben haben das ist auch so ein ding wo irgendwie kaum kaum eine partei habe ich zumindest den
eindruck so eine ordentliche zukunftsvision hat es werden über kurz oder lang in nächsten jahren
sicherlich die ein oder anderen jobs einfach nicht mehr existieren was machen mit den leuten allem
ihrem enormen einsatz zu verdanken dass trotz der bitteren umstände wenigstens ein bisschen schule
gemacht werden konnte im februar 2021 hat bildungsministerin karliczek im rahmen der
neuen initiativ ich kenne die leute null ich kenne echt die leute absolut nicht mehr ich
wusste gar nicht dass das bild das ist unsere bildungsministerium im ministerin ist die digitale
bildung gesagt digitale bildung ist so wichtig wie lesen und schreiben sie hat recht die
erkenntnis kommt 20 jahre zu spät aber jetzt die erkenntnis ist glaube ich immer noch nicht
wirklich da bei vielen zu tun man plant eine nationale bildungsplattform die gelder aus dem
digitalpakt fließen schneller vieles läuft heute schon deutlich besser als vor einem jahr
es wäre ja auch gut das wäre auch schlimm wenn ich in der digitalisierung endlich aufholen wir
müssen wichtig ist übrigens das ist das was ich auch bei infrastruktur gerade internetausbau
sage es bringt gar nichts wenn wir einfach nur ein bisschen schneller machen als bisher weil
die anderen länder haben 15 jahre vorsprung also du verringerst es den abstand nicht der wird
plus weniger schnell größer wenn du den abstand verringern willst dann musst du aufholen das
heißt du musst schneller sein als die anderen stelle ich mir schwierig vor dass wir bei
irgendwas schneller sind wir brauchen jetzt große visionäre schritte hast du das video von
luiso gesehen mit der ne habe ich nicht und weniger bürokratie die corona krise sollte für unser
bildungssystem als anlass dienen sich neu zu erfinden es war kein schlechtes video an der
sache stimme ich im prinzip mit überein so was haben wir hier sonst noch schön infinite
like glitch wie man kann jetzt selbst like bots bauen hier zeig mal her exquisite
ich wollte kurz chat gucken max ich wohne jetzt für sechs monat beruflich einer pension ich
habe mir dann videos zu vpn angekauft mir nord vpn gekauft das habe ich nicht gesagt das lohnt sich
nicht aber ok in der pension ist tatsächlich was wo ich mir wo ich mir denke das könnte man
könnte man durchaus machen hast du tips was ich unbedingt einstellen muss ich habe keine ahnung
ich habe nord vpn auch nie benutzt ich vermute mal dass die open vpn verwenden unten drunter
so kann ich ja nicht kann ich nicht allzu viel sagen
das stimmt
ja das ist was was ich im leben nicht machen würde ich würde im leben nicht lehrer werden
und ich würde im leben nicht kranken altenpfleger werden gibt so ein paar dinger die wird niemals
mal ja ich glaube im oktober ich glaube im oktober ist oktober oder november wann sind
bundestagswein ich glaube oktober ne exquisite september 26 september ist ja fast oktober geht
auch als oktober geht schon als oktober durch so was gucken wir uns als nächstes an das hier
kassi kommt uns jetzt exzellent da habe ich den anfang schon geguckt irgendwie bis bis hier
irgendwie nach vier minuten ich weiß immer noch nicht um was es geht mir ist nur was aufgefallen
in seinem upload in seinem upload fenster muss ich euch gleich mal zeigen
man muss mal ehrlich sagen die videos von ihm auch wenn ich die ganzen
ganz gerne kucke die könnten eigentlich in der regel alle nur halb so lang sein
das ist bestimmt nicht bestimmt nicht erlaubt von youtube oder
by the way leute leute pass mal auf jetzt war mal richtig heckermann
das video hat viel zu wenig likes wir gehen jetzt einfach hin easy
wie das geht nicht war es ein moment
jetzt exzellent so muss das sein hat es jetzt vollgebracht
das ist garantiert nicht erlaubt zu auto klicken
ok easy fix like dislikes abschalten für unlisted video
da macht er ja werbung für in dem video
das unten verlinkt nicht hat er nicht dieses komische zeug was er da hat im upload ich
habe jetzt mal geguckt dass es irgendein service der keine ahnung machine learning tech algorythmen
hat oder so wo man seine videos angeblich boosten kann für 39 euro im monat also sprich das schlägt
in ein keywords vor und solche dinger ich bin mir nicht so sicher ob das wirklich ob das wirklich
so mach mal ich weiß nicht ob das sich lohnt youtube certified wenn also chat wir können
das mal ausprobieren ich meine 39 euro kann ich kann ich einmal ausprobieren aber ich bezweifle
dass ich damit auf einmal doppelt so viele views bekomme schau mal mal schau mal mal
es ist vor allem ein zweiter channel da dauert sowas immer länger also youtube
priorisiert ja auch die video render sachen je nachdem wer hochlädt das habe ich gemerkt ich
hatte ja mal einen zweiten channel gemacht für ein bisschen overwatch content da haben die dinger
teilweise ewig gerendert und bei mir auf dem hauptchannel ist es in fünf minuten durch
titelforscher der honigbreite ist guter titelforscher ja auch mal hin
die tech funktionen ist ja ich benutze die schreibt immer versuchen halbwegs sinnvolle
sachen reinzuschreiben aber ich habe nicht den eindruck als ist die tech funktion auf
youtube das wo in wien ein video gerankt wird
ok so hier ist was wir gehen zu tun alle drei von uns haben access zu diesem einen
kanal und alle drei von uns haben phones that are android and have all of the necessary setup
pre-arranged naturally i have two phones because everyone needs a burner phone if the police
find you so all we need to do is basically save this unlisted video we're then going
to load up this one video and spam the like button as hard as we physically can are you
ready for this lads are you ready i'm ready this isn't just any video this is a video of
georgie jumping around hat er nicht erzählt das muss das müssen leute sein den der channel
gehört
so this is actual premium content we're sharing here in an unlisted format let's go right
i've saved i'm ready lads let the liking begin commence the liking of the video i also have
an advert for workscapes one of my phones didn't okay and i could already see likes appearing
on the video i can already see likes so it's fine and the video has managed so far zero
views one view and 141 likes this is a decent start would you say for a youtube but but
das ist doch garantiert nicht erlaubt also das kann doch youtube easy feststellen
bleiben die likes wenn es gelistet wird ja
jetzt frage ich mich auf warum das 15 minuten lang ist
der auf macht hinne alter ja ist gut
ja irgendwie ist das langweilig alter das ist das mega okay er hat einen clickport am
start super poggers ist jetzt ja nicht wirklich irgendwas neues
das ist echt übelst in die in die länge gezogen habe ich jetzt keinen bock weiterzugucken
so was schauen wir uns als nächstes an bettel viel 6 leaks ok lassen wir uns von levelcat
wieder gbaden die videos sind immer die videos sind immer
massive gbade der wetten wetten da sagt jetzt wieder 30 sekunden was 30 sekunden was über
battlefield am besten plände dann noch in den tweet ein den innen typ gemacht hat und
sagt das sind quasi da ist insider in force
war dann also so interesting kann das nicht gewesen sein weil ich habe nichts von irgendwelchen
großartigen leaks gesehen die interessant war das habe ich gesehen das habe ich gesehen
dass das wäre mir so nicht mal wert überhaupt einen satz in dem video drüber zu verlieren
ich meine what the fuck who cares was alter das habe ich auch gesehen dieses leak ja und
da haben sie jetzt drüber überlegt ist es der battlefield screen ist es vielleicht
battlefield 4 footage das vorher nie gesehen wurde ich meine scheiß drauf ich meine was
genau soll dieses leak bitte schön aussagen es ist ein screen mit zig artefakten drauf
und man sieht battlefield man sieht nichts was genau soll dieses leak in irgendeiner
art und weise über das spiel sagen es ist gut dass er uns den text vorgelesen hat da
werden wir selbst nicht in der lage gewesen ja man hat gedacht fake weil es so schlecht
aussah ich könnte auch so ein fake machen ich ohne scheiß also da machen wir einfach
ein bisschen photoshop actually new leak is made up nonsense so it's hard to say if those
not be talking about battlefield 6 yet but a former dev had a lot to say about battlefield
5 recently the devs spoke on twitter at length about the infamous ttk 2.0 update for battlefield
5 apparently they wanted to implement firestorms armor mechanic is a combat role in multiplayer
assault players would get an armor place their launcher so that they could use it to replace
mr.
sleeper the idea was that the armor would increase the average time to kill of the game
without making enemies feel like bullet sponges while the armor system worked fine in firestorm
and other battle royale games it probably would have made battlefield 5's multiplayer feel
more inconsistent than it already does either way it's an interesting idea but dice scrapped
it along with expanding the combat roles and implemented the ttk 2.0 update both updates
were universally despised by players time to kill update war echt hat niemand gemocht
ich bin gesagt habe das spiel kaum gespielt aber das fanden die leute richtig kacke later
reverted daisy creator dean hall is back with a new game called icarus he and the development
team did a gameplay stream late yesterday evening it showed the opening moments of the game
base crafting in the games inventory system one point to note is that the stuttering you
see in the game plays from their capture system for the stream and not happening in the game
overall the game looks like a mashup of allheim daisy and the cycle icarus is a survival game
but instead of spawning on the map and ok juck mich null juck mich so also es war tibet
es war wieder typisches tibet video im prinzip gab's gab's nix gab nix übrigens das ist
das game was ich vorhin meinte vom daisy typ hat nämlich weil irgendjemand gesagt hat der
würde das gar nicht machen dass das das was ich meine echter lieg jetzt kommt rick roll oder
sowas wahrscheinlich ne das gucken wir jetzt nicht jetzt nicht jetzt nicht jetzt auch nicht
auch nicht ja auch nicht oder das was der fack auch nicht das wollte ich gucken den gucke
ich den gucke ich immer gern aber das ist glaube ich nix was euch großartig interessiert
staubsauger robot mit selbst lehrenden behältern eigentlich könnte sie auch die streams als
reactions auf jutach nähe nähe doch poggers mit selbst mit selbst selbst lehrenden behältern
was gucken wir jetzt ein bisschen lauter stellt klar wenn er wieder was sagt
ich hoffe sowas landet nie in einem staubsauger robot alter das ist ja ein halbes asia asia
gericht schieda fadde doch wichtig für mich ist kann man die flaschen oder ohne cloud betreiben
also wenn man die dinger ohne cloud betreiben kann bin ich sofort dabei ja das kann ich
das kann ich auch machen bei meiner meiner tut sich ein bisschen schwer an manchen ecken
aber hängen bleibt da selten
also den den den staubsauger robot kann er angeblich auch nass wischen verwende ich nie
in the interest of transparency i should mention that nebot sent me this early unit of their
nebot nomo for review in october and it had a rough first two weeks where it would just
randomly stop and it's been a long time i know brauch i just about for was send it back
to nebot and told him that i wasn't interested since it clearly didn't follow my first rule
of robotic vacuum cleaners but they told me they were aware of the issue and it was going
to be fixed in software after a firmware update in early november my nebot has performed pretty
flawlessly since then i did spend my own money for the ecovax t8 with auto empty bin which
i got on sale at best buy in early december hey das ist relativ das ist glaube relativ
günstig für 800 dollar but at the same time the nebot nomo was on sale for 399 dollars
so it seems like you're always going to pay at least a little bit more for the t8 also
fürs wohnzimmer braucht ja ungefähr eine viertel stunde i don't do sponsored reviews you're
going to hear my honest thoughts kann ich dir sagen mein letztes mal letztes mal ich hab
den neu gestartet ich hoffe da hat sich das gemerkt seit dem neustart habe ich schon nichts
gemacht das mal gucken wie lange hat die letzte reinigung gedauert 19 minuten 51 für 10 quadratmeter
ja das schafft habe ich dann extra teppich modus deswegen braucht er da auch ein bisschen
länger weil er auf dem teppich extra hoch dreht und versucht den teppich besonders sauber zu machen
also er braucht hier 10 quadratmeter was fast nur auch was was echt zu einem großen teil aus
teppich besteht also aus höherem teppich braucht er 19 19 minuten
exquisite
this video is sponsored by pcbway.com if you're a tinkerer inventor sellout modus you are
seriously missing out they obviously produce full featured printed circuit boards with a
ton of different materials and options but now they offer basically everything you need
to turn your ideas into a physical reality whether you need 3x injection molding cnc machining
assembly or just plain old pcb manufacturing pcbway can do it all for highly competitive
prices check out pcbway's awesome services using the link in the description to support
this channel let's start by looking at the vacuums themselves the nebot nomo has an all
white glossy finish and a white base on top of the robot you can see the spinning lidar sensor
giving it an overall height of about nine and a half centimeters the nebot has two side
brushes and one main roller brush which has a great design it's the only roller brush
that i've ever i'm completely disassembled on both sides to remove hair tangles and
i hope that other brands take note of this design flipping it back over there are two
front and side for infrared collision sensors and infrared cliff sensors on the underside
the nebot doesn't have mopping and can therefore dedicate more space to it's bin which is
fairly large and pulls out from the back but the resident size is not that important so
it should be able to automatically every time the vacuum returns to the base speaking of
the base the nebot's starting base is 35 centimeters tall and nebot recommends allowing at least
12 inches on either side of the base to allow the vacuum to dock easily but i haven't had
any problems with my setup where it has just over an inch on either side since the nebot's
docking protocol is really precise inside the base is a vacuum bag that nebot recommends
replacing ah die haben quasi einen staubsauger gebaut der den staubsauger aussaugt big brain
your replacement schedule will ultimately depend on how much dust hair and debris you
have in your house and pet owners should expect to be on the lower end the nebot empties its
bin through a single opening on the bottom of the robot and it does so by backing in first
500 dollar also die beiden sind wohl um 500 dollar man muss sagen 500 dollar ist für
diese sache durchaus im rahmen ob das einem das jetzt wert ist muss jeder selbst wissen
die nebot automempte process ist really loud und es bin dub the jet engine by my family but
it does a great job emptying the bin and only struggle to remove it saugt moving over to
the ecovax t8 which is functionally the same as their highest end robot the t8 ai vi but
without the front-facing camera and also das will ich will ich wirklich nicht haben ich
habe kein bock auf einen cloud gestützten staubsauger robot der kameras hat irgendwie
wieder strebt mir das it has a gray and black finish on both the robot and the base ja aus
kein fuchs ich denke schon dass es was bringt ich denke mal er sagt auch wie lange das hält
aktuell muss ich quasi fast jedes mal nachdem das ding gesaugt hat das ding auslernen das
nervt mich also so ein ding was ich nur einmal im monat auslernen müsste oder so wäre schon cool
also muss ich es nicht auslöhren auslehren sondern kann einfach den kompletten beutel in
müll schmeißen neuen beutel rein machen die beutel sind teuer der beutel sah für
mich aus wie ein stink normaler staubsauger beutel
walletudo heißt die custom software aber nicht moment moment muss ich dir zeigen also das da
meinst du also das was ich auf meinem staubsauger robot da drauf hab ja auch mit karte und so das
ist das da das ist das ursprüngliche projekt das hier ist der fork und
der fork hatte ein paar vorteile damals als ich ihn drauf gemacht hat drauf gemacht hab
auf keinen fall die beta inszenieren warum das ist ja letztendlich nur nur nur nur nur
das webinterface da kann es ja nicht viel kaputt machen oder was sowieso was ist was ist damit
nice leak wohnzimmer leak omg
wo bleak ich habe das damals drauf gemacht weil die version hatte eine aktuelle
reform werden mit gebundelt also ein komplettes image zum flaschen hatte
paar andere fixes ich weiß nicht was heute besser ist das original projekt zu flaschen
oder das keine ahnung weiß ich nicht was da gerade angesagter ist ja aber das ist das was
ich verwende dafür die neuen versionen von dem original hat noch nicht alle features ok
du hast zweimal gifs gemacht
ihr zeigt mal wir gucken uns jetzt mal gucken uns jetzt mal neue emotes an
alter was das das ist ja mona es aber zu welchem zu welchem anlass soll man das denn verwenden
andere zehn monat für den zapp was ist ok lasst mal zu welchem anlass würde man das verwenden
mona es anlass woops bin
das nächste ist man hat ein mauszeiger gesehen null oder was man sieht ein mauszeiger was soll
denn das sein das ist das ist quasi imploding brain oder was was weiter unten hier gucke
ich nicht drauf ihr weiß was der monka tos ist gleich am start
woop cursed das finde ich aber cool also das könnten das könnten wir nehmen das könnten
wir nehmen wisst ihr was ich doof finde dass twitch selbst immer noch keine gif emotes unterstützt
das wäre doch echt nice zumal jeder browser überall auf jeder plattform kann gifs
oder schiff's wie die coolen leute sagen schiff's alter der stütz alles schiff's schiff's
braucht man nicht ganz ehrlich bodenwischen ist total overrated wichtig ist kann man die
dinge ohne cloud betreiben weil ich habe keinen bock dass ich abhängig bin von
irgendeiner china chinesen china cloud für meinen staubsauger
willst du deinen emotes in besserer quali größe es wäre auf jeden fall nicht schlecht falls ich
die mal in einem thumbnail und so verwenden würde will ja ja das ist nicht ist nicht verkehrt ja
wäre ganz gut also ich muss sagen ganz ehrlich für leute die allergisch sind denen kann ich
auch eine sache empfehlen holt euch eine klimaanlage mit polenfilter weil gerade in
zeiten also gerade für leute mit mit heuschnupfen wenn man nicht das fenster aufmachen muss und
trotzdem lüften kann ist schon leis ja für falle du brauchst den roborock aber es gibt ja
auch noch andere varianten jetzt nicht unbedingt custom firmen aber zumindest eine lokale cloud
implementierung oder sowas hauptsache leute ich habe echt keinen bock auf den auf den staubsauger der eine
china cloud oder generell internetverbindung braucht die klimaanlage lüftet aber nicht die macht
nur umluft quatsch natürlich oder geht auch nicht die stromrechnung hoch leute passt mal auf also
zeige euch mal die fernbedienung von meiner klimaanlage nein nein nein nein das da die
kann man die kann man auf aufklappen so und ja so ungefähr sieht das aus so du hast vier
verschiedene vier verschiedene betriebsmodi du hast auto so sieht das so sieht das ding aus
das kommt außen hin das kommt in die jeweiligen zimmern das ist die remote dafür also du hast
du hast vier verschiedene modi du hast auto das zähle ich jetzt mal nicht du hast wärmen du hast
kühlen du hast lüften ich muss mal kurz durchklicken was hast du kühlen wärmen trocknen glaube ich
ist das und lüften so und wenn du es lüft wenn du es auf lüften stellst und du brauchst du hast
quasi bis hast hast heuschnupfen dann stellst du es auf lüften und dann zieht das dann lüftet das
dann lüftet das das das zieht von außen luft durch oder dass das vielartig stromverbrauch weil
das das schaufelt ja einfach nur ein bisschen luft raus ja wie macht es das nicht
also ich würde jetzt sagen lüften macht genau das luft von
es ist doch gar keine verbindung vom endgerät zum klima gerät was
meine es gibt keine es gibt keine luft von draußen echt jetzt
aber warum hat das ding warum hat das ding dann polenfilter
lüften
ah
excellent der chat der chat kennt sich aus kühlen heizen lüften
big brain chat da lernt man noch was
die anderen habe ich glaube also die die ich die ich auf pfeifer bestellt habe die habe ich schon in
etwas höherer quali
ja siehst du ok habe ich wieder was gelernt
ich habe mir schon ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen
ja siehst du ok habe ich wieder was gelernt ich dachte eigentlich dass das funktioniert
ich lüfte immer mit dem fenster ich habe kein heul schnupfen aber ich dachte halt die
funktion macht genau das wupp da könnte man jetzt dass sie maut gut für verwenden aber
ok guck mal weiter das stimmt das stimmt
hast du die klima anlage eigentlich smart gemacht ja ich kann die fernsteuern mit
esp 32 und ein frau rot led dran
ja das ist generell die beste zeit einen staubsauger robot fahren zu lassen wenn
man nicht da ist
jetzt gucken wir uns zusammen den müll an jetzt sehen wir jetzt sehen wir die china
fahne in aktion ich habe ein haustier das juckt das also die katz die guckt den
staubsauger robot da schon ein bisschen kritisch an aber ansonsten hat die da gar keine großartigen
schmerzen mit
als wird das ganze auch noch gewogen oder wie
das ist ja fast das doppelte warum hat er fast das doppelte gesammelt
kein quake
big brain tester hat einfach die stockwerke geswitcht mit den zwei robotern
okay genau
Aber auch Sleiche wie unten.
Im Prinzip das Sleiche.
In dem Fall der Nebot, kann das von dem Fakt sein, dass ein ziemlich schweres Brasselett auf dem ersten Test gestoppt wurde und das die gesamte Masse erhöht hat. Aber was ist mit der T8?
Auf die weitere Inspektion, sieht die Schleiche aus, als ob sie irgendwann in den letzten 30 Tagen geschlägt wurde.
Und es gab eine zusätzliche 28 Gramm Schleiche, die von der Auto-Empty-Base zu empfohlen wurde.
Ich bin nicht sicher, ob das der Fall war, weil die Schleiche voll war oder ob ein bestimmter Rund so viel Dreck produziert wurde, dass die Schleiche nicht entfernt werden konnte.
Da hätte ich ja keinen Bock drauf, wenn sich das verklumpt und ich dann trotzdem das Ding aufschrauben muss.
Würde ich eh nicht machen, alle 5 Tage.
Ich würde das Ding vielleicht einmal sauber machen, einmal in 30 Tagen.
Das sollte ich bei meinem vielleicht auch mal machen, da ist bestimmt auch schon einiges drin.
Ja, die würde ich am liebsten gar nicht verwenden müssen.
Weil die ganzen App-Geschichten, die könnten ja, theoretisch könnte man sicherlich eine App bauen, die funktioniert offline.
WLAN und Roboter ins WLAN und einfach in einem Smartphone drauf zugreifen, aber das machen die nicht.
Du brauchst immer irgendwelche komischen Cloud-Surfaces und ich habe keinen Bock, dass mein Roboter, mein Staubsauger nur funktioniert, wenn ich die Internetverbindung habe.
Halskrieg.
Okay, das ist natürlich cool.
Ja, aber auch nur wenn es an Internetzugang geht, wahrscheinlich.
Die haben eine Home Assistant Integration, die muss ich mir gleich mal angucken.
Mal gucken, was der Kram in Deutschland kostet.
Ja, siehst du, siehst du, du brauchst wieder irgendwelchen chinesischen Cloud-Kacke.
Wetten, wetten bei uns kostet 600 Euro oder so.
Okay, ich muss jetzt mal gucken.
Ich muss jetzt mal gucken, was der Kram kostet.
Also, Eco Wax T8 Plus hieß das Ding, ne?
Haha, lull, ich sag noch, bei uns kostet es wahrscheinlich 600 Euro. Warum ist das einfach mal 200 Euro teurer? What the fuck?
Der Typ hat 445 Dollar dafür bezahlt. Wollte ich mich rollen?
So, und was jetzt die Home Assistant, was kostet denn der andere? Wie hieß das andere Ding? Neabot? Neamo oder so?
Zack, ah, wie hieß das Ding? Neabot, Neamo, meine Güte, was für ein Name, kann schon keiner merken.
Okay, der kostet bei uns auch 499, das ist ähnlich.
Aber der fällt für mich raus, nur über die App-Bedienung ist der für ein Arsch. So, das andere hat angeblich eine Home Assistant.
Eco Wax Home Assistant Integration. Wenn die offline geht, stelle ich mir so ein Ding. Easy. Aber nur wenn die offline geht.
So, Eco Wax Integration, okay, geht nicht offline. Username, Password, das geht nur über die AP-Schnittstelle von denen, geht nicht offline.
Wie viel kostet mein jetziger Roborock S550, je nachdem, ich glaube S50 heißt es in Deutschland. Gibt es gerade nicht mehr, ich glaube.
Ich glaube ich habe irgendwie 350 oder so damals für bezahlt oder 250, 300, ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt nicht mehr.
Den kann man halt flashen, das ist das Coole daran. Linux Tech Tips Video über Home Assistant, den muss ich mir nicht angucken.
So, also, Eco Wax Account, okay, das funktioniert nur online. Haben die auch Vacuum? Haben die auch einen Self-Empty? Ah, nee, das ist...
Viyomi. Viyomi S9. Warum heißt das Ding jetzt auf einmal Viyomi und nicht eine Güte? Die Benamung der China-Chinesen ist wieder Wahnsinn, äh.
Vacuum. Kost? Bei uns nicht erhältlich, äh. Ah, Banggood, bei Banggood kann man die kaufen. Banggood für 516, okay.
Versus. Okay, ich würde sagen, da warte ich, da warte ich vielleicht nochmal ein Jahr, bevor ich so einen Selbstreinigenden kaufe.
Ich finde das Produkt an sich cool, aber warum geht das alles immer nur mit Internetverbindungen? Muss das echt sein?
Ja. Ah, das Suck. Please refer die Sucks Library. Es gibt ernsthaft eine Library, die heißt Suck. Oh, und das ist sogar, das ist sogar, ähm,
es wird nicht mehr unterstützt. Na toll. Also, es ist davon auszugehen, dass es mit Home Assistant gar nicht funktioniert richtig.
Also, ich habe ja das doofe Gefühl, das funktioniert nicht richtig mit Home Assistant. Die suckt ja richtig, ja. Ah, das ist das Problem mit so Cloud-Only-Scheiße, äh.
Du kannst es immer nur exakt mit dem Herstellerkram richtig zuverlässig verwenden und wenn der Hersteller keinen Bock mehr hat, hast du auch gelitten und ohne Internetzugang hast du auch gelitten.
Warum kann man es nicht, warum schafft man es nicht, sowas steuerbar zu machen über irgendwas Normales, ja? Dass das Ding eine lokale API hat, die ich ansprechen kann.
Ich meine, mir ist klar, weil die das nicht wollen. Aber, tja. Okay, es benutzt keiner. Scheint ja super zu funktionieren. Oh, was ist das hier?
Ach, die haben jetzt ja, stimmt, die haben seit der letzten, die haben seit der letzten Version so eine, so eine, so eine Analytics-Seite.
Wer was benutzt, kann man übrigens ausschalten, wer das nicht will. Achtung, Flashbang.
Ja, das benutze ich auch. Feuer hatte ich super, weiß, aber das hat, das Problem hat rumgebackt.
Cronaland.
Guck mal, wir haben halb so viel wie die USA an Installations.
Okay, der Sudan, der Sudan hat nicht eine Home Assistant Installation. Ich bin schockiert, Alter. Angola hat, Zimbabwe hat, Nigeria, Ghana, Alter, Marokko, zwei, Ägypten, Austral.
Wait.
Ist das Installation, ich würde sagen, das sind absolute Installation. Die meisten Leute haben das Reporting wahrscheinlich nicht an und nicht abgedatet. Ja, guck.
Amazon Alexa Installation habe ich nicht installiert, null.
What the fuck haben die alle viele, äh, ich habe zwanzig oder so.
Home Assistant Cloud habe ich auch nicht. Den habe ich am Start. FFmpeg, wozu braucht man das?
Tja.
Interessant. Na gut, schauen wir mal weiter.
Hat Cronland, Cronland?
Äh, warte mal, nein, Cronland hat keine.
Unik, das war doch mal in irgendeinem Video, ne?
Das ist Dänemark, warte mal, wo ist Dänemark?
Hier, ne, irgendwo hier ist Dänemark.
Hat der Vatikan welche? Ich glaube der Vatikan steht hier gar nicht als Einzelplan drauf, das ist alles Italien.
Andorra, ist Andorra drauf?
Ah, hier ist zwei Installationen in Andorra, Alter.
Ah, guck mal, hier ist der Vatikan, hä? Der Vatikan hat, und San Marino hat eine Installation, der Vatikan hat keine.
Sieht man eigentlich das Containerschiff? Warte mal.
Moment, wo ist denn das überhaupt?
Ist das hier mit dem Kanal, wo das Containerschiff? Moment, wo war denn das Containerschiff? Hier?
Oder hier?
Ist das hier?
Oder da?
Wo soll ich das wissen? Ich habe mir das noch nie angeguckt, ich weiß so grob, wo das ist.
Na gut, kommen wir uns mal ein paar Witze noch an.
Warum braucht das Internet Zugang?
Ohne Internetzugang, oder zumindest die Möglichkeit, das nur lokal zu steuern, dass man den Internetzugang blocken könnte.
So, warte mal.
Without Internet.
Offline.
Ja super, ich kann auf den Knopf drücken und dann fährt er, das ist ja nicht sinnvoll. Warum, warum kann ich die App nicht verwenden ohne Internetzugang?
Vor allem, warum kann ich das Ding nicht einfach steuern?
Ach.
Sack, das geht mir auf den Keks.
Der Erfolg von Valve, oder Valve, wie die cool Leute das natürlich sagen, Valve.
Ich persönlich bin ja für Valve.
So, also, gucken wir mal weiter. Volvo, richtig.
Jetzt haben wir hier Wreck for Intel NUC und Raspberry Pi. Okay, zeig mal her, was hat er am Start?
Was hat er am Start?
Jeff, Jeff, Jeff. Jeff von der Overwatch Team.
Ja.
Äh, Moment, ich höre nur noch links was.
Okay, Leute, ich scrolle ein bisschen vor. Was hat er hier am Start?
Das sieht aber relativ gut produziert aus, muss ich sagen.
Das ist kein 3D-gedruckter Shit.
Okay, was kostet das? 75 Euro!
Alter!
75 Euro! Nein, nein, 90 Euro inklusive Tax, Alter!
90 Euro für ein Wreck-Ding!
Das ist wahrscheinlich Metall, aber trotzdem. Alter, das ist teuer.
Wo ist denn hier der Link dazu? Da, hier? Ah, Niederlande.
Ja, das ist das Teil.
Okay, das ist billiger. What the fuck?
Our best, Alter.
Aber selbst, aber ohne Scheiß, selbst 65 Euro für so ein Kram ist einfach krass teuer.
Nee, das ist... Nee, nee, nee.
Okay, was gucken wir uns jetzt an? Leute, ich kriege Hunger, as fuck.
Wir gucken uns jetzt für die excellent Big Brain Profis, muss auch mal sein, Top 10 CSS-Tipps an.
Wo würdest du den Intel NUC kaufen? Weiß nicht, bei Amazon?
Ich habe wirklich keinen NUC gekauft, weil ich Pizzi Express wollte.
Stimmt doch überhaupt nicht. So painful finde ich CSS gar nicht.
Counter-Strike Source.
Okay, Pro-Tip. Excellent.
Warum nicht? Warum nicht?
Ich fühle mich immer zu dumm für CSS.
Gerade wenn es um Flexbox-Ausrichtungssachen geht und sowas.
Weißt du, an was ich denken muss? Kennt ihr noch diesen Typ, der seine Frau so doof auslacht, wenn sie sagt, sie will sich scheiden lassen?
Typ, wie heißt der Typ? Was muss ich suchen? Wie hieß das?
Der Typ, der Typ, genau. Der Typ.
Das ist so dumm, Alter.
Irgendwie hat mich das jetzt voll daran erinnert, ich weiß auch nicht.
Ja, da tue ich mir auch immer schwer mit, Alter. Was ist jetzt, wann ist Margin, was und wann ist Padding und wann ist Border und so.
Es ist so einfach.
Ja, das stimmt, das ist auch tatsächlich eine Sache, wo ich manchmal denke, hey, ich soll öfters mal Firefox verwenden.
Das ist cool, das ist echt nice.
Ich hasse es. Ohne Scheiß. CSS-Layout, ich kriege Anfälle. Das sieht nie so aus, wie ich das haben will.
Ja, das weiß ich, wie es geht. Das weiß ich, wie es geht mit Flexbox. Mit Flexbox kannst du einfach reingehen und sagen, Align Center und Item Center, glaube ich.
Ja.
Ja, genau. Das ist das einzige, was man mit Flexbox merken kann.
Es kommt Grid.
Was ist das? Ah, Dreamweaver, Alter. Beste, beste Leute. Dreamweaver, ich sage euch. Kennt das noch jemand?
Richtiges Boomer-Tool, aber damals das beste, was es gegeben hat. Die hatten damals schon Syntax-Highlight und Autocomplete für HTML.
Das ist echt poggers, das Ding. Dreamweaver. Noch bevor die das verkauft haben.
Okay, das ist mir zu hoch. Das habe ich noch nie so genau gecheckt, was diese unterschiedlichen Dinger hier heißen.
Der Auskenn-Fuchs hier aus dem Chat, der hat das übrigens drauf im Grid-Layout.
Ah, ja.
Huge responsive.
Da muss ich sagen, wir haben uns ja mal hier ein bisschen Tailwind angeguckt im Stream. Das fand ich echt nice, dass die dafür fertige Klassen haben, wo du einfach sagen kannst, ab dieser Größe einfach das applyn. Das war cool.
Was?
Ich hätte gar keinen Plastenschimmer, was das überhaupt tut. Was macht das denn überhaupt?
Natürlich. Emoji-fian, alles Emoji-fian.
Doch, doch. Emojis müssen überall hin.
Da wäre ich im Leben da drauf gekommen. Ach, das gibt's. Das gibt's. Alter, ich kann da nicht mal Schritt halten mit Browser-Entwicklung.
Wer braucht Refactoring? Einfach einmal hinschreiben und nie wieder ändern.
Und immer wenn man was ändern will, einfach komplett rewrite. Ich habe eine Idee, Leute. Ich bringe ein Buch, daraus könnte man einen super Agile-Kurs machen.
Immutable Programming. Du programmierst was und sobald es fertig ist, änderst du es nie mehr, sondern schreibst es immer wieder neu, wenn du eine neue Funktion brauchst. Immutable Programming, Leute. Ich sag's euch. Jetzt wird das nächste große Teil gleich mal anmelden.
Ja, also CSS-Variablen sind tatsächlich eine echt poggers Angelegenheit.
Quick CSS-Buffs.
What, what, what, what? What is happening?
Big brain.
So low IQ-mäßig würde ich das wahrscheinlich machen oder ich mache eine Vue.js, eine Schleife oder so. Was? Was zum? Was? Das gibt's. Das habe ich noch nie im Leben gesehen.
Das ist zu 11-Hat für mich, glaube ich. 69-Hat, Alter.
Ach du Scheiße. Ja Moment, wie greife ich denn dann auf die Variable zu?
Wie füge ich die denn dann ein im Text zum Beispiel?
Bevor.
Das habe ich letztens aber schon mal irgendwo gesehen.
Das haben die aber Tailwind auch unten drunter.
Jetzt wissen wir wieder Bescheid. Jetzt haben wir Ahnung, jetzt haben wir Durchblick.
Oh, stellt's den da rum. Ist bestimmt alles voller Spinnen, Alter. Da wird's schnell reingehen.
Ich habe das gerade mit Mansplaining verwechselt. Gibt's ja beides, ja. Mansplaining und Mansspreading, Alter. Oh meine Fresse, Alter. Wenn man sonst keine Probleme hat, äh.
Dürfen sich eigentlich auch Männer über Mansspreading aufregen?
Weil ich meine, in der Bahn gibt es ja Männer, die sich so breit machen, dass sie den halben Sitz neben sich belegen.
Da habe ich, dann habe ich auch was gegen Mansspreading. Wobei, ehrlich gesagt, mir das egal ist, ob das ein Mann ist, der da spreadet und ich auf den anderen Sitzplatz nicht kann.
Oder ob das irgendwelche Mädels mit Gepäck sind. Es geht mir beides auf den Kicks. Ja, zu Corona-Zeiten ist das natürlich was anderes.
Nee, ich rede nicht von Leuten, die zu dick sind, dass du nicht neben sie kommst. Ich rede explizit von Leuten, die sich breit machen, dass du nicht neben sie kommst.
Oder irgendwie ihr Gepäck auf dem Vierersitz verteilen, dass du nicht in dich dahin kannst.
Der Chat interviziert sich jetzt als Frau. So, so. Wollt ihr das machen wie in der 1 South Park Folge? Kennt ihr die, wo dieser Muskelmann bei irgendeiner Frauensport-Weltmeisterschaft mitgemacht hat?
Da waren auch übelst Leute getriggert. Stellt euch vor, 2021 von South Park getriggert sein, Alter.
Okay Leute, ich krieg echt Hunger. Langsam sind wir 3 Stunden am Start. Gucken wir uns irgendwas an, wir haben so viele Videos noch offen, Alter.
Ich werde das schonmal kurz saven. Alles hier saven. Book mark all tabs. Bäm. Und schon haben wir einen neuen Ordner mit allen tabs drin. Massive Browser Hack. Google hasst diesen Trick.
Da braucht man keinen Addon. Man braucht keinen Addon. Das ist eingebaut im Browser. Man braucht dafür keinen Addon.
Gibt es das in Firefox auch? Das ist eine gute Frage. Weiß ich gar nicht, ob es das in Firefox auch gibt.
Mal auf hier. Google. KQW. Bookmarks Toolbar. Ne, anscheinend. Bookmark. Bookmark Selected Tabs. Ja, das geht in Firefox auch. Easy.
Easy. So Leute, ich glaube ich geh jetzt was essen. Ich hab übelst Hunger. Vielleicht sehen wir uns heute Abend nochmal im Stream.
Bisschen Broggastells oder irgendwie Bastelkram oder irgendwas. Mal gucken. Ruhig mal schauen. Bis denn. Machts gut. Ist der Frasier am Start? Ist der Frasier am Start?
Mal raus mit dem jetzt. Der Friesi. Ist der Friesi am Start? Nein. Der Friesi ist nicht am Start.
Leute, wir sehen uns. Bis denn. Machts gut. Ich geh jetzt futtern. See you.